Like she is so beautiful. I don't know why she does this. It
like hurts me. >> I feel like you're doing a an op right
now. So, I'm going to let you cook. You do your own thing. >> What
do you mean?
>> She cannot do her makeup for the life of her. She also
didn't dye her roots. So, her she dyes her hair black, but her
roots come in lighter. So, it looks like she's balding, but she's
not. She just needs to do her roots. She also like does not take
care of her skin. I don't know what she's doing with her eyebrows
lately. Like
>> I don't >> Skin is a thing here for sure. Yeah.
Well, unfortunately >> I don't know why she always looks
greasy. I Why
>> presidential acts? Total immunity on >> Can I
engage in that? >> Yeah. I I mean I I think obviously it's
it's very difficult difficult to dismantle it because this perception
has been built up by the media, by Hollywood, by politicians.
>> I'm here. The party has arrived.
>> What's up? How's it going?
>> It's going so good. I saw that you were reviewing this.
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. You You were like totally in love with
Kai for a while,
>> I I thought Kai was the cutest thing ever. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Cool. Yeah. Review
>> back. He looks good. He looks like um like a Fallout
character.
Well, he did just come back from Argentina, so it's very much
the lifestyle he might have been living.
>> just came back. He might have Wait,
>> I think he came back a while ago. >> Is Argentina
world an
>> Yeah. Isn't that funny? >> That is funny actually.
>> Decades. This is something that goes all the way back
to the aftermath of World War II where you have perspectives
either, you know, the tenants of fascism that are supported by
Alberto X. >> Oh, wait. I'm presenting, right? You can
see this. >> Yeah, I can >> go. Or the ones that
are outlined in Secular Humanism, the magazine. >> I got
to I got to debate somebody after this, by the way. But you you
can stay for that, but I got to talk to someone who's in that
chat, okay? About the Ethan Klein lawsuits. You can argue on
their side or something. It'll be fine. >> 14 tenants of
fascism, which very frequently concern things that are just simply
right-wing in their nature. Things like a traditional mentality
towards generals. Things like the idea that the state does not
need to be libertarian. All of these things begin finding themselves
as part of an authoritarian personality. The exact thing that
is being deemed a gateway to violent extremism by becoming and
it is a way of dismantling the rightwing. See, that's the problem.
That's that's a thing that I think you really need to that that's
a it's a hard conversation to be had because you're like Ometo
Echo his 14 tenants of fascism. It does outline some conservative
values in there for sure. Now, here's the thing. Maybe we should
be I I don't know.
It just it just looks it's crazy like just from phronology alone.
>> I know I already said this. I said there's two like
literally Kai doesn't have to do anything and he just wins. So
I know >> it's so brutal. He's mogging like crazy. He could
say any He could say every single black person and people would
still be on his side.
>> I already made this point. I >> know how else
to acknowledge that. Maybe >> Just copying my points. I
didn't say that part though. That was >> servatism does
lead to fascism. >> He He would never Hold on. He would
never do that because he's a Christian. Okay. He's a Mormon.
He would never do >> That That unfortunately these two
ide
>> uh he streams on YouTube.
>> Oh, interesting. >> Pulled this thing up earlier.
Or was it? You still have it here. It's like Kai Schwam. Kai
Schwam. I I literally was like, "Oh, I could probably get him
on stream." Like only streams every once in a while. Three days
ago he streamed birthday stream.
he was popping for a second. >> Was he Was he getting like
a lot of viewers? I didn't think he was ever that >> He
was for a second.
>> Like where? >> He's getting as much as much as
you on
>> On R Wait, when on Rumble?
>> Uh God, like two, three years ago. >> Really?
I don't recall that.
I didn't think but I still say he got he got the Nick Fuentes
um like sign off. >> I don't know what that means.
>> Like he like he was he Nick Fuentes was like saying
he was like a cool guy. So he had a lot of Fuentes viewers.
>> Oh well. It's sorry it wasn't it wasn't Rumble. It was
Cozy. >> Oh, okay. Those were his numbers on Cozy. I was
I was just looking up his Rumble account to see if he >> was
streaming there. >> Oh, he is doing his streams there as
well. 195 followers.
Okay. So, he's getting like 400 people on Cozy.
>> He was. Yeah. Back back in the day. >> That's
pretty big. That's pretty big. >> Are inherently tied to
each other. Now, I'm not saying you have to be a conservative
to be to be a fascist or you have to be a fascist to be a conservative.
I think the problem is
>> uh what was this debate titled? Would like to watch
it in full sometime. Oh, we watched I think we watched the whole
thing. I mean, if you just want to watch it, it's um >> it's
like the Amfest
America event, and there's a bunch of debates on the title card.
Um I'm guessing
I'm guessing Destiny's channel will have like the full thing
at some point in the next couple days.
You probably America would have it as
but I'm guessing they'll break it up and and put it into segments
and stuff. Did you see how badly they up they had a big headline
debate for this and they like Z totally it up? Did you see any
of that? >> No, I didn't. I I didn't know that this was
happening until literally five minutes ago.
>> Oh, they had like a whole bunch
They had not a whole bunch. They had Andrew Wilson and Myron
Gaines were supposed to be arguing against Destiny and Adam Mockler.
Adam Macher's like a big liberal guy. Um and then like Andrew's
team was arguing like, "Hey, can we get longer openers?" And
basically she refused to negotiate with them on longer openers.
It was kind of just being like a total about it in DMs was like
actually like talking to them and then they dropped out and then
they just didn't have a headline debate for this. So it was like
>> wait who?
>> Andrew Wilson and Mron Gains. They dropped out of the
debate. >> Oh wait,
why? Sorry. Sorry. I was like half paying attention. >> Because
they were negotiating for like longer opening times for the debate.
They want they're like we want to have like a 10-minute intro
for our position or whatever. >> And they long. Z was like,
"No, no, no. We can't do" And I think they came down to five
minutes and Z is like, "No, we can't do five minutes. We have
to do three minutes because we want more Tik Tok clips or something."
It was like her >> And over those two minutes, >> she
started getting like rude and then they're like, "Yeah, never
mind." And then she accused them of never wanting to do it anyway.
>> Yeah. It's it's like actually crazy. >> The person
who runs on from America,
>> is that the
>> um that is the person Andrew Wilson has been calling
BS, but she is in fact a woman. She's literally pregnant.
>> Wait, what do they look like? Will you show me? I don't
[__] up. >> Sure. Let me Let me see here. Uh,
guys, we are off of Twitter. Okay. So, we're off of Twitch. We're
going over to kick. Okay. Kick.comstlk.
You want to keep watching, head over to
We're going to continue the content there, but I'm going to have
to end on Twitch here. Okay, guys. Sorry. Sorry. Head over to
kick. >> My bad.
No, it's not you. It's not No, it's not you. It's uh I'm going
to play stuff
>> crazy. It's half me. >> Oh, also 20 minutes, guys.
We need
what? Four subs. Three subs.
>> Immediately wanting to a woman for her look. Shocking.
When have you ever ever seen me not comment on a man? Also,
>> like I This is not >> when these two came up.
>> Yeah, I'm an equal opportunity.
I There's no
>> Oh,
by the way, you might have tuned in. You missed it, though. Um,
this is the next debate. That one just got called This is the
next debate. >> You recognize? >> Yeah, I I I did.
I I thought that Sarah Stark was hot,
>> but she's not
>> uh She has She has like the What is it? >> You
know, like the you know, like the Yeah. You know, like the the
blonde soy jack like ideal trad wife archetype, that's like who
she is precisely.
>> Yeah. But like >> I think if you're going to say
she's like not hot, I think you're like out of your mind. But
I I understand how that's not some people's preference. >> No,
no, no. I think she's I think she's hot in like an extremely
approachable way. She's like very attainably She's like girl
next door.
>> Okay, I'll just You can have your opinion. She's She's
like a thin blonde girl. She's not like I I don't know.
>> Hard to explain. >> Okay. All right. >> Here.
This is uh Myron Gaines and this person ran into each other the
other day and she was she was him for some other stuff. Said
he got
>> This is Z.
Unlike you. My husband can get me pregnant. You
>> I didn't get kicked out.
there this is the person.
>> In the video.
>> Okay. Yeah. >> I was thinking of another person.
>> Can I ask you something? Just be honest with me.
>> How did Myra know she was, >> you know? I don't
know.
>> guy This guy's like looking up people's like Wikipedia
early life. It's [__]
Yeah. So they had this whole thing and then is it uncensored
America like leaked 30dms? Uncensored America I
Okay, good one. Uncensored
Okay. Why? Why
uncensored AM? Okay, there we go. They like leaked the DMs and
the DMs came out and it was like they asked for five to 10 minute
openings. They asked for five minutes and then she comes back
like board says we can't make do more than three minute openings.
So, like they had this whole room for like four hours. They could
have easily just shaved time off of the other debates, right?
Like now that I know they could have shaved time off of the other
debates, it's actually even more unreasonable that they wouldn't
accommodate the 10-minute intros that Myron and uh what's his
name wanted? Myron and Andrew.
But anyway, basically, it's these leaked. It >> makes sense
to have hitters like that not talk for longer. like of why would
Oh, maybe it was payment.
>> No. Well, basically they're like, "We want 14 more minutes
for this debate out of everything." And she's like, "Well, if
you want to pay for it." And then I didn't even realize how bad
this is. She said, "Oh, well, it cost us 20,000 for the venue.
If you want to cover the venue, then you can have longer." >> What
the [__]
It's like totally [__]
And then eventually, do you know how much it would cost to add
14 additional minutes is what that's how long we need for longer
opening statements. She says, I I have no clue because for them
it's about the principle of making sure it's not boring and they
give viral content. They already weren't crazy about giving Andrew
a platform in general, blah blah blah blah blah. And like none
of these even make sense, but basically >> Andrew Andrew
is like the like one of
more moderate out of that group. I don't
>> He's just
>> But he's his political views are like not that insane.
He's just like a >> Um no, they're they're pretty out there
in a lot of ways. The social views at least. But >> like
what?
um like reworking
uh suffrage like in general like reworking
I guess repealing the 19th amendment is his big is the
>> I don't even know that he really argues for like we
need to take the vote away from the women he does but like I
don't know if he really politically pushed for that or spend
the political capital on it but he does believe that it shouldn't
just be universal suffrage it should be like you have to invest
in some way in the country which like >> I believe that
too I think that only homeowners should vote
>> I believe in terms of ideals I don't the idea of like
of becoming of like getting your vote based on but then I think
there's also no taxation without representation.
So if you want to if you want to give up that tax base that's
some people might welcome that. Hey, I don't need to vote. I
don't want to >> Yeah, I think that makes sense. >> Don't
tax me.
>> Yeah. So >> that makes sense. >> Uh yeah.
So basically then they said never mind. We're not going to do
it. And Z like Z made a bunch of claims about what Andrew was
saying to get out of this and they leaked the DMs and it looked
like Z was just being a [__] the whole time.
Like I can say they didn't want to do 10-minute intros or something,
but that's okay. You don't want to do 10-minute intros. That's
fine. But it's not like they're being unreasonable. They cut
it down to five minutes. They're like, "Hey, can we get five
minute intros?" She's like, "No, no, no. We only want to do three."
I just got the feeling they felt like this group wasn't serious,
you know?
Yeah, I guess that I don't 3 minutes is still a long time to
[__] talk.
>> somebody wants me to show this on screen and they paid
me an obscene amount of money to show it. So, I'll show it real
quick. You guys can get your snarking out of your system. Okay.
And then I am and then I am removing it from the screen. Absolutely
disgusting. Totally disavow this image. I was paid an obscene
amount of money to show it and now I'm closing it. >> I
actually don't mind her features. I I I like um I like strong
features like that. I It bothers me when someone just looks like
they have like a blank face. She doesn't have a blank. She's
interesting looking.
>> She is interesting looking. Would you say you had a
full body shock? >> Oh my god.
>> Yeah. Subversive features. I I do like subversive features.
I don't think she's that bad looking.
>> I don't think she's badl looking. I think it's like
she's got a comically strong chin.
Like like And when I say comics, I don't mean like comically
like funny. I mean comics as in like it looks like something
out of >> comics. It's absurd.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> But I I think um I like features
that that uh move you or they like stir you. So I I I do I don't
I don't mind the way she looks. >> I don't think she's
like an ugly person.
>> No, she definitely needs to get a blow out though. Bad.
Dude, why >> the ramen noodle hair is if you're going to
if you have curly hair, it needs to be brown.
It's brutal. Okay. >> You know, as a strong chin, >> I
like strong chins.
>> Yeah, it's not comparable,
but it's fine.
It's like a >> holy [__] >> baseball
jersey or something.
>> Oh my god.
>> It says not so aerodite on it.
>> You know, it's so crazy because she is so much more
beautiful than Sarah Stark. Like in the face. Like she is so
beautiful. I don't know why she does this. It like hurts me.
>> Okay. I feel like you're doing a an op right now. So
I'm going to let you cook. You do your own thing. >> What
do you mean?
>> I don't know. I don't know why everyone dude if you
genuinely go do a close-up on her face.
>> Please. I say anybody question is you correct me if
I'm wrong about the Bible.
>> She has
such Okay, genuinely take a look. Okay, I'm going to walk you
through this. This is not
>> extremely symmetrical face.
extremely symmetrical face, beautiful almond shaped eyes.
Her nose is very good. Her midface is is perfect.
She cannot do her makeup
for the life of her. She also didn't dye her roots, so her she
dyes her hair black, but her roots come in lighter, so it looks
like she's balding, but she's not. She just needs to do her roots.
>> But she is genuinely very very
She just
I don't know what I don't know why she does this. I don't know
why she does. She has a couple pictures here. I'll send you one
on her Instagram
where she look so you can put it up on stream
>> where she looks so
and it me off so bad that she does this. She also like does not
take care of her skin. I don't know what she's doing with her
eyebrows lately. Like
>> I don't >> skin is a thing here for sure. Yeah.
Well, unfortunately >> I don't know why she always looks
greasy. I Why? >> My
understanding is that God gave up godliness to come.
>> She's been posting a lot on Instagram. Hold on. It's
going to take me a second.
This is really hard. She has like horrible pictures. Does she
not have like a normal
>> Here, I'm giving you two seconds to cook on your own.
I'll hit play on this again and just let this run for like 2
seconds cuz I'll I just need to go grab some water. I'll be right
back. >> I'm actually come down to earth, right? He sacrificed
it. >> No, he did not. Jesus is also a god and >> Yeah,
but he also became man, right?
>> I mean, do you want me to just pull up the verse for
you? God's sacrificial love. We can just go there if you want.
>> Understand that Jesus is fully God and fully man. Yes.
Okay, great. So, God sacrificed by coming down. He in fact he
sacrificed so much that he died for not just his friends, not
just white Americans, but for I'm assuming the world, right?
>> Okay. So, sacrificial love seems to be a pretty fundamental
piece of Christian ethos. Would you not agree? >> Yeah.
Are you going to respond to my claim that ordered love is virtuous?
Like, do Okay. What do you think? Like if I were to feed my neighbor's
kids, but my own kids went hungry. Do you think that's virtuous
cuz you're loving your neighbor's kids? >> It depend on
if you're feeling that you're called to do so, right? I would
imagine that God would probably say that you would split it,
right? Like I don't know in what world,
I have one loaf of bread. I can't possibly figure out fractions
and just like give all of it >> Poor people exist. So yeah,
that is definitely a >> I don't know how that's a rebuttal.
You're right. Poor people do exist. Thank you. Rich people exist.
Yes. Yes. White people exist. saying that's not a poss. There
is quite literally a Bible verse that says
wait. If you're going to say the Bible, there's a Bible verse.
>> I didn't realize that. This is another example of Erdite
like totally mocking a tactic that she uses later in the debate.
Um, trillions of dollars exist. Um, don't you know that trillions
of dollars and fractions exist?
Wait, actually, she just used it. Wait, there's no way it's that
obvious, is there? Hold on. >> Suffering. you can help
them out, but there is a certain >> wait later in the debate
there's the trillions of dollars exist, fractions
And then she's mocking Sarah for saying poor people exist here.
It's so weird.
Like you have a pet peeve around some tactic and then you just
use it openly yourself all the time. Isn't that bizarre? Feels
very bizarre.
>> Dude, I'm putting in work on this edit right now.
>> Okay. Oh, you are 100% running an op right now.
>> am I banned? You're not banned.
>> thing. This is the original picture. Okay. This is the
original picture.
>> And then this is the other picture where live is saying
this is what could be a
>> Hold on. >> Okay. So the difference
the difference here are a lash a more flattering color for her
>> slightly thinner eyebrows.
>> It's it's subtle changes,
>> but she she looks more natural. She looks younger.
I did not make her eyes bigger. I just added a lash. >> Yeah,
I think Facetune does stuff you don't intend to have happen.
>> No, literally put them next to each other. There there's
literally men don't realize that a lash and a little bit of eyeliner
changes your face.
>> Okay. Wow. >> It It would just be It would She
would just look better. She would just look better. And I don't
know.
Let's see. It's so hard to find like a video or a picture of
her.
Oh, this is going to be it. This is going to be the thing. Holy
[__] >> Oh, this is going to be it. Everyone's
gonna freak out. Hold on. Wow.
Ready to have my mind blown.
>> You're actually gonna freak out.
This is actually going to be crazy.
Okay, let me add some lashes. >> Pretty sure even less
wants to argue that the Ethan Klein stuff is dumb,
I believe. So, we'll see if he actually comes in and argues that.
See if he makes it at some point. We're just waiting. We're just
waiting,
>> dude. Okay. Are you ready? >> Uh, yeah, sure.
>> I sent
not changing my mind on whether or not we're running an op. Okay,
>> there's this guy and then
there's this guy. >> Slightly lighter hair color, a little
bit of a thinned brow and a lash and a different hairstyle. She
cuts her hair in like a mullet. She needs to let it grow out
and get a blowout. She's like, look at the I didn't change her
features at all. At all. Okay. >> But they just they look
better with her features.
I need to give her a makeover like immediately.
>> She really like the bones of it. Like she has such a
beautiful face. I don't like she really just needs a little bit.
She really just needs a little a little bit of a little tweak.
>> Why is she wearing a dog color in this? >> Like
look at She looks so much younger with a lighter hair color.
>> I agree. When you facetune erodite a lot, she looks
younger.
No, it's not fake. I haven't changed any of her features.
>> I haven't changed even one of her features. Her nose
is the same. Her cheekbones are the same. Her lips are the same.
Everything is the same except for her makeup.
Her eyebrow and her hair. She could She could be like a nine
or 10.
>> Zip zip zip. Oh my god.
Uh man, you haven't been following anything. We uh
basically have like Destiny claiming that my community is like
uh evil now. You followed any of that? Well, he's been doing
it for a while. Like threatening to dox people here and basically
said he he's going to dox anybody he can in the Discord, I think.
>> So, uh we just been >> Yeah, I think any information
he can. He's posted doxes of people. Like full doces of people
like crazy full doces of >> I just don't know. Why is he
Why is he doing that?
I think he's like mentally broken.
>> I mean, yeah, obviously he's like humm Imagine like
imagine you're on top of the world and you're like a huge bully
and then you're like you're like gross little putrid gets leaked
and you're a like that is so brutal. >> I'm probably going
to cut away from I I understand you do it once. I don't care
if you do it once. Probably to cut away from the jokes.
>> Why adisement?
Um because
I would like to have it so that the claims are mostly based on
facts cuz he's totally factually in the wrong
and so I don't want to give him to like like go James J's mean
and he like let's laugh talking about my on his
>> Why don't you just say disavow?
>> Just say disavow.
>> His is factually gross. >> No no no no no no.
I just don't want to do it. I understand you want to do it, but
you're about to start streaming, so you can go do it all you
like on your stream. >> Amount of resources. >> That's
true. Should I get back in his
>> Uh, if you want to. >> Who's in his orbit now?
>> Who's in his orbit now? Um, that Zip Zip person I was
talking about. Oh, if you want to turn your cam back on, you
can. Um, that Zip Zip person.
Um, food shops. Food Chops is a big one. Dan and Mr. >> Foods
is like actually like drooling like brain damage.
>> I know. It's very funny. like turbo autism patient zero
for terminal autism. >> I don't I don't even think it's
like the autism. I think it's like actually like they somehow
if they were white and in the percentile of IQ that they represent
in Asians like like they're like a fifth percentile IQ person
for Asians. If they were white they would be actually profoundly
they would need like a caretaker. They're just lucky that they're
in the Asian group.
>> Yeah. I think I have a hard time believing that food
shops can live on his own, his her,
he, she.
Jesus Christ. What even is it? I don't even know what it is.
>> I think Teto made that point once.
Race and IQ takes. Let's go. I'm saying Asians are very smart
and like percentile wise it's like like they might actually be
somebody with Down syndrome but it's like Asian Down syndrome
so you don't even know they like kind of
debate and then
>> oh the D we we covered the DB debate um the good points
>> I don't really want to revisit we could we could do
clips if you want >> I'd like to see >> I'd rather
like if I was going to revisit this I'd rather revisit this but
we could we could do something. Let's >> We could do that.
I can I can revisit this. She is really beautiful. Even that
still she really is. >> I think I think Elav's doing some
kind of OP with this that I'm unaware of.
>> Dude, shut up. I She need the next time she does one
of these appearances, she needs to hire me.
>> I'm being dead ser I'm being dead
so quickly. >> That's not true. Well, it's kind of true,
but it's like, listen, Asians are just smart as a population.
I don't know what to tell you. I'm not saying anything about
Well, I am kind of actually saying explicitly that. Whatever.
Whatever. It's fine. Are you turning your camera back on or am
I taking this down?
>> I don't know. Now, I'm nervous.
>> Might have to move this down somewhere like that or
something.
They're like squinty J boys a little bit. Yeah, but like less
financially inclined, more like I don't even know. Oh, I might
have to move.
How do I do this in a way that works? Maybe I just move this
off entirely and I move lav like that or something.
Yeah, that'll work. That'll work.
Okay, we could recover this maybe. The doobie thing was kind
of rough because he tries to bring up the Lauren de Laguna stuff
which is
like that Destiny harassed Lauren de Laguna and I don't think
he necessarily knew very much of it
unlucky >> I don't know much
>> you guys so much you guys Catholics typically do I think
some sects of Mormon also anybody that agrees to is what do you
mean by Christian because I
>> America first is not
speak loud and we're fighting There we go. >> I got you.
I got you. >> Aristo looks like she likes to ride on. >> The
topic today is America first is not
>> Okay. So, I guess my first question is
what do you mean by Christian? Because I believe I don't know.
>> Who are these two girls debating? One of them is not
so airy. The other one's Sarah Stark. Sarah St. somebody with
like 200,000 followers on Twitter. White nationalist. America
first.
you might remember her for you might remember her from the right-wing
egirl civil war that happened that included Lav's former podcast
co-host who we learned got fingerbanged in a hotel at a Turning
Point USA event. Okay. In a hotel lobby. Lab, do you ever comment
on
>> That happened. >> Emily Saves America. Emily >> Yeah.
Saves America. Yeah.
>> I Why didn't >> she got [__] She got
groped. She didn't get like it wasn't consensual. It was non-consensual.
did he say that? >> She didn't I don't even think that
she commented on it because she doesn't want to accuse anyone
of anything. But that's how people know of that thing is because
she literally was like >> that's soed up that everybody
was talking about this and it was non-consensual. That's actually
really >> didn't want She didn't want to talk about it
cuz she has a serious boyfriend. She didn't want to be like no
this guy. She didn't want to talk about it. It was like weird
that anyone brought it up.
It is weird that somebody brought it up and now I feel like I
feel for bringing it up a little bit, but also I'm like, dude,
why did
that's crazy. In right-wing circles, you just let people grope
you and then call you a [__] because
accusing somebody of rape would get you blacklisted.
>> I'm pretty sure he was also married to >> groping
would get you blacklisted.
>> I'm pretty sure. Who is it? Elijah >> Was it Elijah
Schaefer? I don't know. Most likely >> suspect. I might
have just dropped lore that I wasn't supposed to drop. >> To
be fair, that is that is very very believable. If it were Elijah
Schaefer, that would be completely
>> well, that's a little public is that Elijah Schaefer
did like he's a little freak and he tells >> not just like
>> MAGA practis at this point though, grabbing him by the
>> dude that whole sphere is so gnarly.
all of these like right-wing people each other and like each
other and it's like it's up. >> I do believe that that
is like the if you were a that is the primary that is like the
best spot to be in. It's like hey I'm going to in the sphere
where if any of the women accuse me even if they're correct >> they
actually lose by accusing me.
>> It's pretty wild man. I also could be
I don't This was like three years ago that I learned this. I
don't even know if that if it was really Elijah, but I know that
Emily is not that kind of girl. Emily's great. >> Oh, wait,
hold on, hold on, hold on. You just said she's not that kind
of girl, but then another allegation here was that she um brags
about having sex with married manga dads.
Is that a thing? >> That's like just not It's literally
just not true.
>> She's like had a serious boyfriend this whole time.
I don't like it's so stupid. >> Well, that wasn't about
I was asking what she claimed.
>> I She's never We got close and she never bragged about
that to me ever.
She's pretty serious about a career. Like
She's focused on that. She's not really >> Does she ever
respond to this?
>> I think that she's tried not to cuz she has a boyfriend.
>> Okay, I get that. But I'm just looking for like
she like dropped out of this
>> Some wild. >> I don't I don't think that she made
a comment on it because like you're damned if you do, you're
damned if you don't. >> That's pretty wild, dude. Dude,
>> I think I'm having a stroke. >> Dude, that makes
this meme like so much worse. That make this meme is really like
way less funny now. That's up. >> I'm stroking.
>> Jesus Christ.
Are you good?
I can't see your camera at all, just so you know.
>> we'll we'll go with this debate one more >> Know
like what specific denomination you subscribe to. So, like >> I
would say anybody that agrees to the apostles creed fundamentally
is typically viewed as Christian. So, anybody that uh appeals
to those that thing? So, Protestants, Catholics typically do.
I think some sects of Mormon also appeal to the Apostles
>> Eastern Orthodox.
>> Okay. Um Okay.
Wait, are you taking your camera down by moving this off? >> Yeah,
I'm having a stroke.
>> Okay. Boom. Done. >> So, why do you think this?
Okay. Uh, let me clarify. You are America first, I'm assuming,
since you agree to it. But you're also a Christian nationalist.
>> Okay. Square that circle for me. What's ex What exactly
is >> What is this? Oh, somebody else asked who these people
are. Sarah Stock, notite. They're debating America first is not
Christian.
Um, I think Arerodite loses this debate really hard almost immediately
and then she kind of wins on some of the finer points of like
immigration at the end. I remember correctly >> is America
first about being a Christian nationalist like >> well
well the question is is being America first Christian? I would
argue that 100% is and we can look at St. Thomas Aquinas's idea
of ordered love meaning you have a responsibility to the people
closest to you. So, just like it's immoral if you were to feed
your neighbor's kids while your own kids go hungry, it's equally
immoral to support policies that harm your country's people but
benefit those from other countries. >> Oh, um, we'll do
this if we want more time after this, guys. I think we're
>> maybe five four subs from another hour. >> And
this has been explained in the catechism as well. So, >> that's
really weird. So, you correct me if I'm wrong about the Bible.
My understanding is that God gave up godliness to come down to
earth, right? He sacrificed it. >> No, he did not. Jesus
is also a god. >> Yeah, but he also became man, right?
>> I hate the way that she talks to people. It's so annoying.
how to be how to be unlikable 101. >> Dude,
uh
listen, keep some powder dry, okay? cuz that was about as
>> normal and approachable human being as not every day
pulls off in this entire conversation. Was that was that was
like the nicest most normal she is. >> Uh Matt, thank you
very much for the five gifted and chatty nickel I believe was
the other one. Thank you very much for the gifted sub. >> All right,
let's go. >> Do you want me to just pull up the verse for
you? God's sacrificial love. We can just go there if you want.
>> Understand that Jesus is fully God and fully man. Yes.
>> Okay, great. So God sacrificed by coming down. He in
fact he sacrificed so much.
So like Aronite was wrong right there. God God did not give up
godliness,
right? And she's the one who's acting like she was correct and
the other >> for you. God sacrificial love. We can just
go there. >> Understand that Jesus is fully God and fully
man. Yes. >> Okay, great. So God sacrificed by coming down.
In fact, he sacrificed so much that he died for not just his
friends, not just white Americans, but >> so like
like I just have to you can only have meta conversations with
these people that point out that their level of condescension
and
is entirely unearned.
Entirely unearned.
Hold on. God did not give up godliness. There's There's no giving
up godliness, Missy Elliot. She's not correct. She's correct
when she starts again and she doesn't say the thing that she
knows is wrong,
but she is being condescending already to somebody who hasn't
been condescending to her, who stated their beliefs, right? And
she's just doing this is a this is a DG special. She's just doing
tone indicators,
right? As in look at how dumb this person is. And they're completely
unearned. At least Destiny can try to earn them sometimes, at least
in contentious conversations.
But Sarasto doesn't know to like go and call her on this. Wait,
no. You understand that? I'm not saying God wasn't sacrificed,
that Jesus wasn't sacrificed. I'm saying God did Jesus as in
God did not give up godliness. There was no giving up godliness
to become the son to come down as the son and sacrifice himself.
>> But for I'm assuming the world, right? >> Okay.
So, sacrificial love seems to be a pretty fundamental piece of
Christian ethos. Would you not agree? >> Yeah. Are you
going to respond to my claim that ordered love is virtuous? Like
do Okay. What do you think? Like if I were to feed my neighbor's
kids, but my own kids went hungry. >> I think that's
>> rich kid cadence that's like but stupid. I don't really
know much about Sarah Stark, but her like her vocal cadence is
like um
it's like lower register and it just makes her sound dumb.
Like uh you know Trump's like great niece or something. What's
her name? Kai something.
I've seen the person.
>> It's like it's just like slow and like
like chromosomally.
>> And it bothers me. I hate when people talk like that.
>> Yeah. Wow. Um I don't really know. I don't know. I wasn't
focusing on her tone too much. I'll be honest. Like that Theodos
lady. No, it's not like that. I would pick that up. That's incredibly
offputting. I don't think it's the same >> No, that's like
she sounds smart. This is like it's like broken. Her she takes
pauses in the wrong places. It's hard to explain. I should be
I should research
>> Oh, I thought she was she sounded smart for a little
bit when she's trying to focus on her points. She knew to go
back to like her point that wasn't engaged with and then at some
point she runs out of stuff that she's like practiced on and
you can tell where the split is. I >> cuz you're loving
your neighbor's kiss. >> It depend on if you're feeling
that you're called to do so, right? I would imagine that God
would probably say that you would split it, right? Like I don't
know in what world be like I have one loaf of bread. I can't
possibly figure out fractions and just like give all of it away.
>> Poor people exist. So yeah, that is definitely a >> I
don't know how that's a rebuttal. You're right. Poor people do
exist. Thank you. Rich people exist. Yes. Yes. White people.
>> I don't know why you're saying that's not a poss. There
is quite literally a Bible verse that says no wait. If you're
going to cite the Bible, there is a Bible verse that quite literally
says that if you were to feed that if you were to take care of
someone else's child before your own, you are worse than an unbelievable
but then an unbelievable site where that's from. >> It's
in first Timothy something. I don't >> Okay. I'm I'm sure
>> that that does exist by the way. So Ardite was just
like, "Um, yeah, I'm sure that does exist. That exists. We look
it up." >> I don't even understand
Kyla's like religiosity. Like what are you you like
you hang out with? Like and you're like in a weird like relationship
with a man who's 53.
>> What are you? >> True. My biggest indictment of
Erin's Christianity is her 5 foot three >> That's true.
She's like she's like they're like polyamorous like they're in
like a they're in like a polycule or something. They're like
weird ass people. Like what is it
weird?
>> I agree with everything else you said except possib
except for the comment on Nick's height. I agree with like all
the other stuff is very weird. I feel like those are all like
like the vibes are just off for somebody who's like super religious
and committed to
those ideals. I think the whole idea that she has where she says,
"Oh, I don't apply like my morality to anyone else." I think
that's not Christian at all. Um,
I do think the idea of morality is like un it's it's universal
universalizable.
It's like universalized, right? Like you're trying to get into
heaven. You try to encourage everybody to get into heaven. That's
how your morality works. Everybody believes that you can't apply
Christian morality to non-Christians.
>> What's that?
Well, because she's just she thinks it's more of a philosophy
than like anything else. She's >> Yeah, but >> really
she's really actually she's unironically. She lives like a
>> I think she would make that argument. That's what Connor
does, right? Connor is like he he tries to make the cultural
Christian argument. I believe there's like a name for it. What
was the name for it? I forget,
>> right? No, it's not. There's a name for it. It is. It
is very It's like non-godfeuring and it's phil it's philosophical
rather than
you know.
>> No, Conor. There's a Is it deist? There's there's a
name for it that we looked up. There's >> It is. You guys
can look it up. That's a >> Sure. So, here's one of the
issues, right? Is you're creating >> So, like Erdites,
Dude, this is the thing, man. She She's like all tone indicator.
She's like trying to make it seem like this person's well wrong.
And I can't I don't understand how it doesn't like totally crush
you
when like this is right here. This thing over the this is a less
egregious version of the whistleblower moment happening again
where she just says this verse doesn't exist. You're wrong. Uh
you're a complete for saying it exists and then it does exist.
I It's right here.
Anyone who does not provide for their relatives and especially
for their own household has denied the faith and is worse than
an unbeliever. And like this would be a part of the the reasoning
behind the what is it ordered love thing that Thomas Aquinus
was talking about. But she just like acts incredulous and and
mocks the other person. >> Like this world where essentially
I have a loaf of bread and I'm going hm actually I'm going to
give none of this. But the America first like look at America
right now, right? America doesn't go we're actually going to
spend zero money on Americans. We're not going to have welfare.
we actually do have these things and then we also do things like
us aid which I imagine you're opposed to and so the whole issue
with being a Christian is there is a fundamental piece which
is caretaking of others right if you want to look for example
I'm sure you know this do you know the parable of like the good
>> yes I do >> okay so what is what happens in the
good
>> there's why why are you yes I understand like if someone
is um suffering you can help them out but there is a certain
amount of resources that America has if If we were to give away
all of our resources to other countries and our own people because
nobody is saying give away all of our resources. >> There's
a limited amount of resources.
>> that is true. >> Just like there is familial level
there also is when it comes to your >> I can't believe
how oh this whole debate. Do you remember when Sarah said homeless
people exist and now everyday goes fractions exist?
It's like she literally every tactic that she mocks Sarah for
in this debate that she tries to like do the straw man voice
like the soy. Yeah. Fractions. Yeah. You think I mean this? Do
you think I mean that? Every single thing she mocks Sarah for
doing in this debate she does herself is baffling.
>> This is like >> Do you think that what I'm
>> she like she's always done this. I Kyla's like
she really is like um just so severely unlikable which kind of
makes me like her.
>> No, it's not like the kind of I I can like people who
are unlikable. I can like Kai because he's like >> he's
like evil. I can just tell he's like smiles.
>> But like this this is like unlikable in the ways that
like people are just actually unlikable. Like it's not unlikable
in the like oh you say something egregious once in a while. It's
unlikable as in like she is aggressively like trying to humiliate
somebody who she knows nothing about who she just met because
she >> it's so benign because she's like it's almost like
she's a child like she's it's almost like you can tell that she
was very sheltered in her youth and she just like she lacks self-awareness
in the way like a teenager would. >> What based on what?
>> What do you mean? What what about her condescending
to this person means she was sheltered in her youth?
>> No, ju like just the way that she just the way that
she talks like her excitability right now. It's like this is
the way that like a teenager debates.
>> But you No, no, no. The offensive thing about that is
that she we've already seen who she was before she entered the
space. This is not who she is. She was never like this. This
is all performance. This is all like a skin she put on after
the fact. >> Well, yes, exactly. That's what I'm saying.
like she's you can tell that like her identity is like fragile
like a teenager. That's literally what I'm saying to you. >> Okay.
I feel like that's not what you were saying, but I could maybe
understand that that she doesn't have her own personal identity
and so she gloms on to anybody she thinks looks cool or strong.
>> Yes. But yeah, she lacks the self-awareness to like
know that that's like weird and that she's like skinwalking and
doing something that is like
awkward. >> Okay. Because I would agree with you.
>> I would agree with you that she lacks the self-awareness,
but it's not like she's not aware. She doesn't have the self-awareness,
but I do I am aware that she is aware that this is offputting
cuz I do believe she started DMCAing people who point this out.
>> Oh, well, yeah. I think she's just uh she's like awkward
and it makes you I don't know. It makes you kind of like feel
bad.
It's like it's an uncomfortable watch. >> I would feel
bad if I didn't know that she like intentionally
tries to take like the things Destiny's done and make them more
palatable palatable to people exclusively because it economically
benefits her. Um if that wasn't who she was, I would feel like
bad for her. I don't feel bad for her. >> Yeah. I don't
But you have to understand like this is she isn't she from like
a small town? This is like >> her relationship with the
closest she'll get to have like a career. She's just like a normal
girl.
>> Sure. I just I need to uh Missy Elliot, she is like
Just Lane Maxwell. Like this is like like Kyle the Kyla Maxwell
thing I thought was wrong at the time is like completely correct
to just say she's a part of the cult is not to state it strongly
enough. She's like a leader. She is like an enabler. She is like
working as hard as she can to to make the cult take off again.
Just to be clear. Sorry, I did kind of cut you off though. My
bad.
>> Yeah. I didn't know that's totally true.
>> She was a PhD student with a promising academic career
before. Destiny, that's I don't think that's true. >> She
was not a PhD
>> I think she was trying to get a masters. I don't Does
she have it? >> She had she had like a she was in like
a
>> Wait, maybe she maybe she skipped her masters to go
to a PhD program. She had a graduate diploma.
She had a graduate
but maybe she could have worked on something further.
She had a graduate diploma, I think, or was working on her graduate
diploma. >> She has a bachelor's and a certificate.
>> So, she doesn't have like a Is it right to say that
you have a master's? Was it Maybe I'm misunder I thought she
was in a program for a graduate diploma and I don't think she
finished it. She was in like a one-year program for a graduate
>> and then I do believe she tried skipping that and going
into a PhD program. I think there was something like that that
happened. I thought,
but I don't I don't know. Yeah, it's a it's a diploma. It's like
a certification.
>> Well, they let anyone into college. I'm I got into college.
Can you believe that? I'm on like a full ride scholarship. They
literally let anyone into college.
>> Damn. Lagona got a masters. Look, I you could be books
smart. I think people are just saying that they're surprised
she did this. I think
I think this is a field that can be very exciting. you have like
unbounded potential.
So it's like very exciting when you first start
and reality hits. Okay. >> Advocating for when I'm saying
that America first so when I say America first is on Christian
is because fundamentally what it does is it looks at every resource
that America has the number one economy in the world right trillions.
It's worth trillions of dollars a year and it says
>> this is a just foundationally terrible argument. My
god >> this outfit is like hurting me. It's giving me a
migraine. >> You know what?
>> She's like, she's just like uh Harley Quinn, isn't she
just like Harley Quinn? She's got like a baseball uniform that's
like half one color, half the other color. It's like mly. Isn't
that cool? >> We can't help others. It has to fundamentally
be about us all the time. Not only Not only is this stupid foreign
policy because soft power is incredibly important and it weakens
our allyships, but on top of this, it's fundamentally selfish.
What you're saying is, "I know I have a lot, but nobody else
can have any of mine." That's not Christian. I'm not saying America
should bankrupt itself and give away all of its money and then
like live in the gutter. That's not what I'm saying. What I'm
saying is that America First supports the banishing of US aid.
It supports not helping Ukraine in the war. That to me is both
fundamentally selfish and
So what I think that America first is about is simply it doesn't
mean we can't help other countries or even other people who live
outside. >> Do you support the banning of US aid? >> Can
I finish please? >> Do you support the banning of US aid?
>> Can can I finish what I was saying? I'm just going to
ask you that we put American interests first. That's what it
means. It it means that we are not
>> Be selfish. I hear you. So even with Ukraine, I mean
even if I'm not even fully against sending any >> I would
uh I would recommend
nobody ever debate not Serite or Destiny. They're like transparently
just looking to make the other side look bad. That they are not
remotely attempting to have any s any kind of conversation. There's
like no purpose in engaging with them ever. It's just very very
like if you are looking to have a career in this field, they
are never ever going to engage with you in any anything approaching
good faith. They are always going to try to make you look as
bad as possible, consistently straw man you talk over you, try
to never engage with when you have like a valid argument at all.
Right? I'm sure there's a way to engage with them to make them
seem insane. Only to your side, right?
Only to your side. Um, with Destiny, he is good enough at it
that I wouldn't. With Arerite, you could definitely make her
look stupid because she constantly commits to positions she can't
defend. Like she does multiple times in this debate as well,
right? Like she constantly says Destiny is much more experienced.
Destiny's much more like
uh much more difficult to do the same thing to.
So, Internet Blood Sports, what's new? Yeah, but like that's
not what they're trying to do, right? They're trying to go, "Well,
nobody will engage with us from over there." and then they don't
actually enga like it's not actual engagement. So yeah, the pisco
debate is just like again echoing in my head. It's like the same
thing I watch happen to Sarah here. Now you can feel less bad
for Sarah because Sarah is probably representing an ideology.
I don't even think she I have no evidence she like truly sincerely
believes in the America first stuff like down to the race realism
and right but she'll represent it because it's making her money.
hard to say who I actually think is like more >> money
or helping out Ukraine at all because if we were to help Ukraine
and that helps America I'm fine with that but I would only help
Ukraine if it helps you very Christian by the way look I'll be
generous to you but only if fundamentally it's good for me guys
you know got to get that money >> on a foreign policy level
if we are >> thoughts oh did Lav walk away for the best
note highlight oh no >> no I just I'm like in pain looking
at her outfit.
>> Yeah. What did you think of the
>> I literally can't focus on anything
>> You You didn't focus on that. >> I It's like Well,
she's just like doing like autism. She's just being >> um
I mean, you call it autism or you could like >> dig into
it. Like I I fully believe that she like >> thinks this
makes her look so cool. That's a >> Have you seen Love
on the Spectrum? >> That's a rough That's a rough one.
A rough one. Have you seen Love on the Spectrum?
>> No. Go ahead. Explain Love on the Spectrum to me. >> There's
like scenes where like the people with Down syndrome are like
talking to
each other
and you get like a sort of feeling in the pit of your stomach
like like these people should not exist
>> because
about Down syndrome people. >> Is there a spectrum? It's
a level of pity where you're like
these people should be put down.
It's uncomfortable for everyone.
>> And I do feel >> those people are though, right?
Not not down syndrome. I don't think >> there might be
a down syndrome one
has some down syndrome. >> They have the down syndrome
ones too. >> They don't let the people the person with
Down syndrome, do they? >> They do. They do.
Dude, that's So, you feel like most people watch that show and
they're like, eugenics is the only way? >> Uh, I feel like
people with a good conscience Yeah, I I I do feel like the average
person, even if you're like super lib,
gets that pit feeling in their stomach, like we should put you
out of your misery.
>> I think that's like a good question is like is like
people have that argument around eugenics, right? Like you technically
could
engage in a eugenics program. You could argue ethically that
eliminates down syndrome people from
>> Probably for most people is not actually like you know
killing like a of human life. Did Iceland do that? Yep. Iceland
is I believe totally without Down syndrome people. >> Yeah.
But most people advocates for people with Down syndrome actually
say that that is like a genocide. There's like a genocide on
Down syndrome.
Yeah, but it is what it is.
>> Yeah. So, it's interesting because that is like the
argument like you
you could just make sure there's no down syndrome people in the
world anymore. It's like that's probably better, but also
I don't know, man. What's your position on it? I don't know.
I haven't really thought about it that much. I like it's one
of those things where it's like it's one of those things where
the I don't have like an overriding principle that like I'm not
just like pro-life at all costs. And so I'm kind of like realistically
I feel like both sides have some arguments.
Like I'm kind of leaning more towards probably allowing it. Like
I don't think you should I think you should have the choice and
that choice is up to you as a parent if you want to raise a kid
with Down syndrome. >> Now do I think like as a rule you
should have to >> Yeah. I think if you have if if they're
ever going to rule you had to terminate. I don't think I support
that. But I do think you should be allowed to terminate because
ultimately I think that comes down to
so is having a kid in general.
>> Not like that. Not like >> you're just you're
just committing to that strain being there for longer. >> No,
it is different. It it's having to to take care of someone or
the state having to take care of someone with high needs like
that.
It It's unnecessary.
It's just
>> Well, the state doesn't have to. I think you would have
to maybe maybe you could say if you're like a homeless crack
addict and you've got like a a baby with Down syndrome and alcohol
syndrome
>> if you're lucky enough to be down syndrome and have
rich parents.
>> Sure. But the like the child will will never usually
not be able to like live on their own or have like any sort of
>> there are downies who live some like relatively meaningful
lives
>> or the ad
they live in they live under care though which is usually like
funded by the state >> I do >> or by rich people.
Um, I do think that
all of the Tik Tok accounts that like try to do the fetish posting
of like the Down Syndrome person, but they're like really uh
they got like the really hot body, but it's all just a filter.
I think that should be illegal. I don't think you should be allowed
to do that. >> Oh my god. Retroish. >> That's like
that's like um that's like running PR campaigns to keep something
in society. Where do you draw the line? If you're going to be
an unnecessary,
you know, just welfare cow,
uh, you should be killed. Yeah. I also think we need to bring
back asylums. Like Nick Reiner needed to be in a nut house. >> It's
not a unique. Realistically, it's like bring back asylums, but
also asylums probably should just be like long-term mental care
facilities. There should be more long-term mental care facilities.
There are some. They're not funed enough right now. >> We
should we should just kill people like that.
>> Um maybe >> like if you're schizophrenic and violent
or if you have like severe down syndrome like you are going you
are being made into hot dogs. Sorry.
>> You're we're fixing world hunger. We're killing those
people making them into hot dogs.
>> Okay. Um let's see. I think the issues come about because
it's difficult to test and figure that out before those people
offend. So, I don't even know if you really save anything by
doing that. It's just like the death penalty in that case, right?
Cuz like Rob Riner was rich. I don't think he'd ever let his
son get tested in some way that like gets his son killed, right?
Like probably there's just no way to prevent that from happening.
His son was probably going to do all of that no matter what.
>> Yeah. It's just
>> like I'm guessing there were actually reasons he could
have gone to jail way before this and Rob Riner was probably
consistently like getting him out of hot >> I haven't looked
into it at all, but I'm I'm guessing that's the the story. >> He
went to I mean he went to rehab 18
>> Yeah, it's incredibly sad. And like apparently they
were working on a documentary like he's a I think I think Oscar
award-winning director and writer that was doing like a documentary
on his son's like struggles with addiction
>> and like got murdered in the middle of that documentary.
Let's be honest if somebody can pick up that documentary that
is like a Oscar winning documentary that could come out. Okay.
You get like all the raw footage of them talking and dude, that
could be powerful, man. Right. Like talking through the issues
and they actually fail to overcome the thing they're trying to
overcome as a family. Like an incredibly sad story.
>> It happens so often. I have a one of my best friends
growing up got addicted to drugs and we muddy in rehab. She went
for like, you know, drugs. I went for eating stuff
and uh we stayed in contact and as she got older it just like
and I was friends with her family too cuz her family was fantastic
liberal family just like the RER family super close um everyone
was a professional wealthy
and she just kept doing drugs and kept going out and kept doing
drugs. She'd like FaceTime me from the hospital, from rehab,
being like, "Haha, isn't this so funny?" with her mom. And her
mom would be like, "We don't know what to do." And then finally,
she did so many drugs um that she like basically I mean she basically
killed herself. She like
>> she
had she had a brain bleed and a and like a stroke. She had like
a bunch of stuff. They had to scoop out like a third of her brain.
And then not going to leave you as foundationally as you think
depending on what parts they have to scoop out. She struggles
a lot. She can still walk. She's really bad aphasia, so she like
cannot find certain words and she talks very slow. It's been
about 10 years now, though. So, it's >> that's like >> it.
I mean, it was so brutal. But, it was the only thing that would
it was the only thing that would make her stop doing drugs. And
then even after that, she still tried to do drugs. Like, there
are just people that like have just they're just so
they're just so And like what do you do with those people? you
like you literally just have to like let them take themselves
out.
Like there's so many parents of addicts that are just like it
would just be easier if you killed yourself. And there's like
a crazy guilt in that. But it's like it's like just what it is.
>> Um Yeah. I mean that's traditionally the story with
a lot of addictions. I don't think I think that's like up to
the people around them. >> Yeah. It's just I think >> I
think for every person I think for every single person >> who
kills the himself in that situation, you have a family member
for everyone that's like, "Oh, thank God it's finally like the
burden's gone." I think you have another family member who would
give anything to spend like one more day with that person. So
I think not necessarily the same person, but like in a similar
situation. So I just don't think it's appropriate to say that
actually we should take these people out. I think there's a lot
of people who miss someone incredibly important in their lives
that they even if they were a burden at times they feel like
they will never get another date with them. That's really so
I >> human condition and sometimes we don't we have to
not listen to that part of our brain and and be more utilitarian.
>> Yeah. But I think that's like foundationally
like that's life. You should get to opt into that conversation.
Get to opt into that question. Like people, so many people think
of the it's like, oh, you just feel guilty and that's the only
reason you do it. No, a lot of people can look at it as like
an overall costbenefit thing and they just care about that person.
Like I can't imagine Rob Briner ever looked at the costbenefit
of taking care of his son and was like, "Oh, I know nothing bad
will ever happen here." I promise you, I bet you that's not even
the first violent confrontation they've had that he's like kept
away from the cops. And I don't think he necessarily would have
just been like, "Well, I should let my son get killed." I don't
think so. If my son was doing that, I'd like I'd put him in a
mental institution. Like I' I would I >> think he went
to mental institutions.
>> I think like an asylum like he needs to be sent away
or like literally Yeah. I think that parents would be able to
kill their kids like actually like actually if your kid is like
>> I don't think that would have happened here. I think
there's a chance you could have showed Rob Reiner his future
and he would have opted every single time to to keep his kid
alive and keep working through that even if he knew one day that
that was going to lead to him getting stabbed to death by his
kid. It sounds like he wasn't willing to give up on his son no
matter what. And I think it sounds sad, >> but I don't
think that I get to go and say that he was stupid for doing that.
>> I don't think that's like my I don't think that's my
place to decide that.
>> Yeah. There's just so many people that like I mean he's
he has a odd story because obviously his family was rich and
they could try. There's so many like I mean California and Austin
and New York are just filled with those people and they're on
the street and they're each other and they're you know >> it's
different that's with people who don't like people have given
up on them right those are the people who would have opted into
your program
like their families have given up on >> these people are
the same at least try to let them hit rock bottom
>> all I mean all those pe you can tell when someone is
better I No, no, no. You can't. No, you literally can't.
>> This isn't This is you. And I don't think I don't think
>> I feel like you know what you're saying is wrong
cuz I think I usually when I talk to people like this, I think
they don't have any experience with people who have had addiction
issues, but I know you have. So, I'm surprised that you're saying
this. >> I I'm telling you there I mean people talk about
this in AA. There are some people who just like will not
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But I'm telling you that
the people who are like hopeless, it takes a long time to figure
out who those people are. And there are people who seem hopeless
who need the right way of like figuring out how to find the light
and they can get out. There are people who are long-term hopeless
and there'd be years that go by and they will turn it all around.
>> It's just
I I there are some people there are some people who like do not
have light behind their eyes and they're just doomed. Like
>> I don't know how to probably agree with you. I probably
agree with you that that is the case. But I do think that that's
not most people. I think there is a problem which is the burden
to get somebody out of that pit. The burden to get somebody out
of that pit is a lot. And there are very few people who take
that on if you don't have like family members who feel dedication
to you. >> And I think that's what happens with like the
people who end up like on the street with mental issues and like
doing drugs and I think that's usually what happens. But it I
would never say that most of those people are hopeless. I think
a lot of those people like I have family members who had periods
where our family thought they were hopeless and then they came
out of it and then they fell down again and they came out of
it again and they're out of it now. And it's like like it's I
just I the idea that most people are hopeless is crazy. But I
guess you just gave that up. So
>> I don't I didn't say most people. I never said that.
>> Yeah. Before you were saying a lot of people and now
you've given up you're like I don't think most people are
>> but I do understand that like there is a there's a burden
where like >> to be a a therapist. I obviously don't think
that most people are hopeless.
>> Okay. Um >> my realistic opinion is that I obviously
I don't think like if we're if I'm getting out of control register
and going back into like normal person. >> Uh I like Yeah.
There's I don't think I don't even think most I think most people
can be helped,
but there are some people
who
won't be just won't be. >> Yeah. Well, I think I think
I have the same opinion on like crime and it it basically comes
down to like is somebody going to stand in and help these people
and I think that's like the great thing about AA or NA is that
it's a group of people who struggled with this and they're there
to lend support to people who are also struggling with it. I
think that's why those organizations are so awesome because it's
like they basic it's like paying it forward basically, right?
you're going to go and you're going to take and help somebody
and pick up some of that burden that like if just one family
member or two family members pick up that burden, it's like impossible
to bear. But if like a group of 10 people can pick it up and
help, then it people can get through it, right?
So I I that's why I really like AA. I but sorry that was all
to say that I think the real problem is sometimes there are people
who just don't have like another they don't have somebody who
can help lighten the load for a little bit and help them get
back to where they need to be and then they end up like just
constantly in like this downward spiral. >> Sure. I I mean
there are
yeah there are human cycles but I I'm just saying literally there
are some people who just have different brain chemistry and no
matter what you do it doesn't matter how much you love them
they just
it's not they're like it's very anim animalistic. It's not you
know I I've said this a lot. We're like the only animals that
think that we're gods. There's some people who are so that still
have their animal brain and
they won't change is what I'm saying. And it's a small population
of people, thank God. But what do we do with those
>> Are you talking about the people who are like under
like have a higher propensity to do like physical harm to others?
That's what you mean? Yeah, I'm Yeah, I'm talking about like,
you know, there's there was like uh like that that huge kid that
was like um like bull like bullying his mom in those like videos
all over Twitter and obviously people like Nick Reiner and um
people like my friend who you know had a a brain bleed. Like
there are just
there are people who are you can't do
man, I don't even I don't know your friend's situation. It's
like you could say you can't do anything. There's probably some
combination of stuff that would work. Usually the problem with
>> I mean no what worked for my friend she like got lobotomized
basically.
>> Sure. I was going to say but like what could have worked
for her possibly I like usually when these situations stay persistent.
It's because the approach of somebody is staying consistent.
So, I would say if you have family members who are consistently
like picking up after you and making sure that you aren't getting
in trouble, aren't hitting rock bottom, that will propel that
will propel these things like decades
out, right? Like your your actual resolution, some actual like
uh you getting better in some way will be like pushed way further
out. Um, not to only blame the family, but I'm saying like if
it's if it's just the person on their own, which is not your
friend, then they if they never get help and they're constantly
at a spiral, that's bad. But I'm saying usually when people have
like some kind of support structure, that support structure is
keeping the person
um afloat or going in a direction that's bad, too. If you have
a support structure that's flexible and willing to change
and you're willing to put any amount of work in yourself and
they're also allow like willing to let you hit rock bottom and
risk that I think I've never seen a case where that person has
like been unable to come back from it. But I also don't have
as much experience as I'm letting on. It's like a couple cases
but it's like a it's like people who love you and care about
you but also are willing to let you hit rock bottom are very
rare. >> Sure. I I I think we were talking about like Down
syndrome and stuff. I mostly when we talk about like addicts
and people who are like severely mentally ill, I I'd say that
there are less people who need to
be taken out or but I think like uh
I I think like the like the big violent
people who like can't control themselves like basically what
we do now is we just like medicate and sedate the [__]
out of them and it doesn't even work and then we put them in
homes and that doesn't work and then they're like you know they're
a strain on resources and they're like basically belong to the
state like
that's what I'm talking about rather than like addiction. Addiction's
tricky cuz it's like really complex.
>> Yeah, sure. Yeah, I
agree. >> And someone said in uh a chat
that I
was unstable.
Actually, a couple people said that I'm a very stable person
in my regular everyday life. I'm a straight A student. I have
a great marriage
>> I I
agree with you, but I also think like arguing that with the chat
or even correcting them is tough, but I'll let you. Sorry, I
didn't mean to cut you off, but I'm just >> No, I just
there there's like this >> I I think that there's like
I don't there is like a narrative and it's still residuals from
Destiny.
>> It's like it's these because he was world building for
and he does this like with everyone obviously everyone who's
his enemy is crazy
but he world built so much that like now even people who hate
him
are still holding on to this narrative that like was created
about me and it's very irritating.
Um, I I don't care if you actually think I'm unstable, but it
is in my everyday life, I'm like I have a fantastic job where
I have authority. And >> I don't feel like you're significantly
more unstable than the average person. I think probably the average
person like also
like,
have you doxed the underage person you were at any point in your
life? It's like we we should put this in degrees like shades
of unstable. Okay, sure. I think generally basically everybody's
unstable to some extent and I don't really I think that's the
problem is people on the internet people like come together as
a society almost to like masquerade and pretend we're all like
we all have our [__] together and basically nobody
really has their [__] together to the degree anyone
pretends and then we cast doubt or we cast judgment on the people
who publicly vent about the that's going on in their lives. It's
like well while also being fully aware that we don't necessarily
have our own [__] together and it's just like making
us feel better. I think that's broadly the pattern that plays
>> Yeah, that's the that's the problem that I have or that
I've seen. There's like a phenomena with like um I don't know
if you're familiar with like the LOL cow live sphere
>> not Keemstar
>> but like there's there's a bunch of people who are like
uh quote milking lol cows and they'll like watch like a bunch
of like very
people who like obviously addicted to like various drugs and
then you'll like go in that chat and the people who are like
bullying the so and so lull cows are like methaddicted polycqle
crazy people and they're like, "Haha, this person's so crazy."
And it's like, "Holy, like
everyone is ins everyone online is
>> Yeah, basically.
>> But that's like that's like the same people who are
like I've gotten into like debates with a lot of people who are
like, "You're crazy. Dusty said you're crazy." And then I'll
like ask them about themselves and they're like
they've been divorced seven times. They've been to jail four
times. And I'm just like, holy. Like, what are you? Yeah. I don't
even know what got me on that on that uh whole
thing. But
>> chatter is casting judgment without knowing the person.
>> Yeah, that's true. But I'm I'm actually like I'm a normal
girl. I do like to though. I'm a I'm a big troll. But I do
>> sometimes a lie just >> pops out. Don't even know
where it came >> Dude, you know that the average person
lies five times a day. Sure. I may I feel like you're lying right
now and that's the joke, but I don't know. >> No, Google
it. The average person lies five times a day. It's normal to
like white lie like, "Did you eat breakfast?" "Oh, yeah, it's
fine. Yeah, I ate breakfast." That's normal.
>> Humans do that. You know how weird it would be if we
were all like
what are we like divergent characters? We're all like Canandor.
You've always you've never ever told a lie ever. Ever. Ever.
Ever.
Come on. No, we lie all the time to each other to make each other
feel good. And
>> yeah, that's lying with intent. I was referencing a
clip where you say sometimes a lie just sometimes open my mouth
and a lie just
sorry that's I was referencing that clip. Come on, man. >> Yeah,
I know. But that but people take that out of context. The whole
>> people take that out of context. The whole thing was
like if it's like about white lies like did you eat this this
day or like me or like trolling
Okay. Sure. >> Like it's it's fun to >> do that one.
>> It's fun to I don't know if you've ever done this, but
like I went to the bar a couple days ago and I was just like
I was just saying things because it was like funny to say things
and I was streaming and uh I just like kept lying to this like
bartender about my life. I was like, "Yeah, I'm like I'm three
times divorced and I'm 31." Like just like just for fun. Like
that's that's what I mean when by lying. That's people do that.
That's fun to do. Is it a little deranged? Yes. But that's fun.
>> Oh man.
How long are you around for? >> How long am I around? >> We
never I never did the Danish deception stuff and I watched a
little bit of it to see like that it was good, but I never actually
did the whole >> I feel like that could actually be really
fun to do with Lav.
>> What is it?
The Danish deception.
>> I don't know what that is. >> It's like a It's
like this Tik Tok Tik Tok story about a woman who meets a guy
and
some happens. Like a little tick like a multi-part Tik Tok series,
but it's it's like pretty funny. I don't know. It's It's long,
but it could be pretty funny. I don't know how long you're around
for. You're like logging off at some point soon. >> I'm
around. There's a word for that live. It's called Duper Delight.
No, that's not duper delight, dude. It's not like it's when you're
talking to a stranger and you're just saying things. It's actually
like socially
adept to be able to like not lie, but
create bits. >> It's fun. >> I'm sure most people
do something to that extent. Most people create narratives around
like events that happen in their lives. Sure. >> Yeah.
Well, I don't want to spoil Porter Beller. I'm explicitly trying
not to
That's why I could tease it. A man, a woman meets a guy and it
sounds like two things are things are too good to be true and
then it turns out that things are probably too good to be true.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
>> They always are because men are [__]
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I've heard that. Also,
>> do we have like footage of that Andrew Tate fight? You
know Andrew Tate had a fight or something, right? Got his app
kicked.
Yeah.
>> Wonder where I'd find that whole thing. But somebody
put a link in the Discord. I want to click on it real quick.
>> My body count. I'm a virgin. >> Hold on. Right
here. >> This is my reaction to Andrew Tate losing his
boxing match against Chase Deore. And als
>> Dude, he got he got up. His his like eyes are >> didn't
really beat him up even though he's got some marks on his face.
>> Chase landed some good uppercuts. wobbled him with an
uppercut at one point in round five partially. Um but it wasn't
that crazy. Um but other than that just whiffed shots, didn't
really land anything clean. Mixed it up in the clinch now and
then with like some baby punches that didn't really land correctly.
Tate, this is such a bad aura loss for Tate.
This is the top G though. You know what I mean?
My opinion of Tate
before this and I think the opinion of Tate has massively dropped
after this or a loss.
>> Do really
>> the fat guy wearing a beanie to hide his receding hairline
his Norwood five is talking about aura and he's in his probably
mid30s.
No wife, no children I suspect by his skull shape. I hate this.
I hate the internet. I hate that people can comment on other
people. It's so weird and [__] up. >> I'm glad
Tekken recognizes this guy. It is the same guy. Yes, it's the
same guy who called Raja Jackson a
an ape who belongs in a zoo. An animal. An animal. This animal
belongs in the zoo. This savage can't even be this tribal evil
savage.
Sorry. Just a classic British guy describing any person um any
brown person in general. Very interesting stuff. See here >> political
scale was abandoned a lot of it matter about
>> just to be loud and to get more attention as well. Maybe
he believes a lot of it.
>> But my overall consensus was doesn't matter about all
of that. >> Doesn't matter about
>> I don't know man. He was getting clipped by some decent
shots early. That was probably the best looking punch chased
through the entire fight by his cut later on.
>> Tate landed a left hook back at one point as well. >> Okay,
that is not a good punch. Holy
>> Fighting. Holy. >> Holy cow, >> dude.
Dude, he's like on
>> he's like on his front foot here. He's not pivoting
any of his weight into this. There's no hips. There's no nothing.
It's like only his arm. That's basically like a That's like a
pitiful slab. Holy [__] See me fight. I can't fight.
I get my ass kicked
>> against Destiny. >> I get my ass kicked >> again.
I probably beat up Destiny. But that's like horrible, dude. I
I would have I I fully believe
>> that if you could give Merc two weeks of training, she
would beat the out of
>> Dude, she could beat if you give her a couple shots
of tequila,
Destiny's dead.
>> Like Destiny's not a fair example because he's like,
"Yeah, I saw the 3 a.m. vibe tweet." Yeah, >> I saw the
Carolyn Quan tweet back as >> I tried retweeting it. My
my [__] broke. My Twitter like broke. It wouldn't
let me post.
>> Destiny's like
170 lbs of soft fat. He's a gynoid male. He's not doing any damage.
His shoulder width is like thinner than his head. It's over.
It's over.
>> It's just the like total lack of any physical exertion
his entire life. Like that he's just always been like a tiny
tiny person. >> He's a noodle. He's made out of cheese
and pasta. He's a noodle. >> I don't even say this is in
like I I'm not even like on him like genuinely.
I just don't think he'd be capable of like fighting anything.
>> No, of course he isn't. My when my husband met him,
he shook his hand and it was like a woman, he said. And then
Dusty and then Destiny asked him like if he was going to kill
him or something because he had a firm handshake. >> Like
I like I think uh
yeah, but I I feel like Goon is the exact kind of guy who's going
to try to like break someone's hand that he thinks is trying
to someone he some girl he likes. Goon is like that person. This
is Goon would have definitely just tried to like break this guy's
hand for sure.
>> This was before I was in the picture. >> No, it
wasn't. No, it wasn't. No, it >> Yes, it was. >> Oh,
sorry. It might have been.
>> Wait, but hold on. Was the situation still the same,
though? Hold on. But was the situation the same? Is that how
they
>> What? They met at TwitchCon.
I wasn't there. >> I was in Twitch. >> In San Diego
three years ago, >> I think so. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So what I'm asking is was was Goon trying to somebody
there that Desty was also trying to and is that why Goon tried
to break his hand?
>> fair enough. I can see that being the >> Yeah.
Know I was not even in the picture. I don't think >> Sure.
Was Kimmy in the picture?
>> I think Kimmy I think he was Kimmy at that point, but
Destiny wasn't trying
>> So they had no reason to beef even Timmy even said that
there was no beef. He like laughed about it, but
>> Oh, fair enough. >> It was He's like scared.
I really hope that I really hope that we run into Destiny someday.
>> I really hope >> you know what matchup would go
hard though in terms of like I think these people have similar
like physical prowess is like Destiny versus Ricky Berwick. I
think that could go pretty
Is that the Is that the thing that's like [__] up?
>> Yeah, that's the thing that's like up. >> That's
like the spider gloop person,
>> I feel like I want to say yes. That's absolutely accurate.
>> The crypted.
>> This is like Ricky Burwick. Yeah. >> Yeah, that's
the creature.
>> There's like a there's like a lot of overlap though.
>> Yes, I
a super chat. $6.91
from a plushy show animated universe.
>> Very similar. >> Ricky, you are grounded. Grounded.
Grounded. Grounded. Grounded. 70 MILLION >> MONEY ANYMORE
right now.
>> By the way, this guy makes so much money on YouTube
right now. This guy streams. His streams get like massive viewership
and he gets like tons of donations the whole time.
>> This guy is like just raking in money streaming. It's
crazy.
This is an abortion.
This is an
>> Yeah. You think Ricky Berwick wouldn't make the cut?
He's auto He's auto gone.
>> He's gone. It's over. Big If I had a child like that,
big rock to the soft spot as God intended. >> Maybe. Yeah.
>> Yeah, I kind of get it. That's rough. But hold on. What
does Ricky have? Does Ricky have something that like they knew
he was going to be like that or does he have something where
um where like it was degenerative but like they did it doesn't
necessarily progress that far or something? I get the feeling
that it was they always knew he's going to be like that but I
don't know what he's got the
>> you I pointed the jersey out so many times that it says
her name on it. >> It's so bad. It's so bad. Like I can't
What is she doing? I don't know what she's doing. It hurts. It
really hurts me. I'm about to cry.
can you detect spinobipida
like before the kid's born? Oh, be hect. >> I think sometimes
you can. >> He does have bees hect. Okay. Congenital
connective tissue disorder.
>> I'm getting angry. >> Just at this picture again.
I'm about to start being really mean.
>> Okay. Well, hold on. Let me see if I can find some of
those tape clips.
Andrew Tate. >> Not so every day's got to be 30 now,
>> I'm googling birthday.
>> What the is this? Like falcon punch a shot like that?
Absolutely not. It's too easy to see. And you know, Andrew Chase
simply fatigued and he was able to get out of the way of it.
Too much weight. Beautiful shot by Chase around the chase. The
more >> When's her birthday? Is she a Virgo? >> I
have no idea.
>> We need to find
>> Nick is a Leo. >> I'm asking why she has Nick.
How old she >> Cuz that would be weird.
>> Say me. His ass says something. I see. I don't think
it says me though, bro. Give me one second. I'll be right back.
>> She is the year of the monkey. She's a sagge. She's
a Capricorn.
She realizes that her career is done after Destiny fizzles out,
right?
I I really think that she's just trying to piggy back off of
it for as long as she can, which is the economical choice. Economical
economic choice.
>> What did you think of this video, Kilo?
Do you think I pulled this video up because I've seen it before
and I really want to show it to Lav or >> You think I pulled
this video up because I haven't watched this video like >> overdosing
on Benadryil to show me this >> Okay. Okay. Yeah. No, you
know what? Maybe not this video. Where is the I have a playlist
for the Danish deception here. Hold on. Danish deception. Here's
the playlist. >> Hello and w
it's long. I don't know if we could do the whole thing, but we'll
we'll try. We'll do we'll go for a little bit. So, this nice
young black lady has a story to tell. >> They have their
hair like this. I think it's so pretty. It's like mermaid.
>> Welcome to a new series that I will be calling the Danish
deception.
And throughout this series, I'm >> Oh, she also speaks
in like the most stereotypical ways.
So, like uh we'll be calling this the Danish deception. be going
through the details and events that happened throughout my threeyear
relationship.
>> You can skip basically the first 30%. No. What? We can
probably skip a couple of these. It's like her she meets a guy
on vacation.
Um things go really well. They like have a spark and then she
like goes to meet him after that and then he just kind of keeps
becoming like cooler and cooler >> with a man from Denmark.
What are you going to do? >> Believe was going to be the
>> What are you going to do when Cherry makes us a 17p
part series about you? >> Probably just acknowledge that
a lot of is true and try to move on.
>> Love of my life >> and the father of my children.
And I now believe him to be the most despicable, two-faced, narcissistic,
evil person I have ever encountered in my entire life. And I
know a lot of you are probably thinking that's a very heavy statement
to make. Believe me, I mean every single
I know a lot of you are probably wondering why are you sharing
your life's most intimate and traumatic experience with a sea
of strangers. Well, there's a multitude of reasons.
>> She's cute. >> No, nobody's really wondering.
This is literally just part for the course now on the internet.
I'm sure she's got some cope justification, but it's like, no,
no, you just you just want to tell a story. It's fine. There's
three big ones and I'm going to share with you the first two
reasons and the third one I'm going to wait and share with you
at the end of the series because I don't want to give anything
away. But the first reason is that this is my way of telling
the world that love is a powerful powerful drug. And if you're
someone that's knowingly or unknowingly in an unhealthy or toxic
relationship, I want you to know.
>> Uh, okay. You guys have about 90 seconds to say things
like, "Spe it up. I don't care about this." Uh, there's got to
be a zero filler playlist. There's got to be like some other
way to do this. You got like 90 seconds here to make those comments.
And after that point, one week bands for every single person
who thinks about complaining. Okay? So go have your have your
fun. Okay, >> dude. You're like have your fun and you're
like an evil overlord.
>> Yes, that's always been the case. This community is
running
police your chat. They can't even say what they >> The
beatings will continue. The beatings will continue until morale
improves.
>> No. Love is a powerful drug and it clouds our judgment
and it makes us think in ways we wouldn't think otherwise. And
if you're someone that's also trusted the wrong person, you're
not alone and you need to give yourself grace and compassion
because it happens every day. The second >> like every
woman >> I needed to hear that. I needed to hear >> is
that this is my >> that I have failings but I need to give
myself grace and compassion every single day. I need to hear
>> way protecting others. This is for >> Whether
it be someone that might encounter my ex or let's be real, there's
some horrible people in this world. I want to protect other people
from going through what I went through. And I if there's one
person that can watch these videos and see some signs in their
relationship that they didn't see before and they can remove
themselves before too much damage is caused, then it's 100% worth
it for me to do what I'm
What you guys are about to hear is going to be one of the most
beautiful love stories you've ever heard in your entire life.
And for that reason, I need to make sure you guys all prepare
yourselves because it's going to take a very drastic turn. And
this is going to be one of the most insane roller coaster of
emotions that you guys have been on. And if you are a fan of
the Who the [__] Did I Marry series, unfortunately,
the story you're about to hear is significantly worse. And it
pains me to say that.
This next part, I'm actually going to channel my inner Reset
Tissa because I loved the way she did her introduction and disclaimer
video.
>> Who's Rhys Tissa?
>> Everything you're about to hear is the truth and can
be verified by multiple people in my life. And I actually have
a folder in my in my phone that's labeled evidence and it can
support probably 80% of the things I'm going to say throughout
this the series. So if my ex or anyone else wants to come forward
and say I'm fabricating any of this, I will be more than happy
to release the receipts to the world.
Um, I'm going to tell the truth even if it makes me look bad.
And there's going to be times that you guys are going to be looking
at me
>> Have you not seen this before? No, I didn't watch it
when it came out and I just thought like the lab probably hasn't
seen it and so might as well just do this now because it's like
kind I know it's I know it's interesting. It was interesting
enough that I was like listening to it I think I listened to
the first four parts or something that I was like oh maybe I'll
cover this on
>> and refer to reason number one. Love is a powerful drug.
>> I'm going to be using a mixture of aliases and real
names because I don't have everyone's permission to use their
names in my priority. >> Okay. Uh I think we are done with
the disclaimer. We can go to the actual story. Okay, >> the
Danish deception part one. Okay, so it all started in June of
2022.
I was in a place in my life where I was working two jobs. I was
working like a dog and I knew I needed a break. So I reached
out to my friend Sarah who was living in Germany at the time
with her husband and I said, "Let's take a trip. Let's go somewhere
in Europe." And she was so down and we were trying to decide
where we wanted to go and we decided to go to Habar, Croatia,
because we wanted somewhere that was like a cute local town that
was by the water, but it wouldn't be as crazy busy as other places
in Europe. And so we decided to go to Habar. We flew to Splitfirst,
met there, took a ferry over and at first I was just so amazed
at how beautiful this place was. And so the first night we're
obvious I was a little bit jetlagged. So we kept it very chill,
grabbed dinner, then went back to our Airbnb. And the next morning
when we woke up, we had literally two things on our agenda and
that was to eat and drink and be by the water. And well, I guess
that's three things, but yeah, eat, drink, and be by the water.
So we went to Hulu Hula, which if you've been to Havar, you've
been to Hulu Hula. this beach club that's very well known there
and it's right on the water and we're laying in dayb beds kind
of off to the side minding our own business sipping mojitos and
I look up and I see this very attractive man and the first thing
that came to my mind was this man looks like he is walking straight
out of a Calvin Klein ad and I'm telling you guys 63 blonde hair
blue eyes chiseled skin so tan muscles everywhere I I was definitely
taking it back and I feel like it takes a lot for me to really
double take a man just based on his lips like that and 100% I
was just I was a little bit just in I didn't even realize that
he was like with a friend >> chiseled skin I mean you know
what she means chiseled skin is not a thing that's not what she
meant like chisel chiseled is just all you need to know >> first
and so I'm still minding my own business keeping it chill and
he >> if this were a guy telling this story everybody just
be like yeah no matter what you tell me from this point on I
understand you're okay let's move on. I don't understand how.
It's like because it's a woman, people don't aren't used to just
hearing like that first part and going like, "Yeah, I don't even
tell." >> He looks over at me and he says, "How are the
drinks?" And I said, "The drinks are wonderful. We're just sipping
mojitos." He said, "Should I get us all around?" And I said,
"Absolutely. Number one, he's cute. Number two, who wouldn't
want a free mojito?" So I said, "Yes." We got a round of drinks
and we're sipping our drinks and we just start small talking
and I asked them where they're from and they say that they're
both from Denmark. Um, my ex was living in Copenhagen and then
his friend was living in a smaller town called Alberg which is
north of Copenhagen and that was actually my ex's hometown that
his friend was still living there and so we were just small
>> really critical information only guys >> talking
the whole time. We didn't really talk about a whole lot of things.
It was just like, "Where are you from?" and just basic things.
But they were asking us, "What's your plan for the rest of the
trip?" And we told them, you know, we're doing a full day boat
excursion tomorrow and then we're going to dinner tonight at
this place called Domatino. And he said, "Oh, how's the dinner
spot?" And I was like, "I don't know, but I got recommended by
a friend to go there." And he was like, "Okay, well, maybe we'll
meet up with you guys again later." And I said, "Sure." So, we're
>> Okay, I feel like I'm going to start navigating based
on what I remember until I get past what I remember cuz this
is like a lot of they go to the dinner place, they miss him,
he messages back. He's like just showing interest. It's a lot
of like him showing interest that she wasn't expecting. >> I'm
also South Africa's happening. I can see it. And the reason why
he said that was because I was telling >> Oh, hold on.
After dinner, we go and grab some drinks at a bar nearby. And
we grabbed one drink and they're definitely gearing up to go
back out. And it was our last night and my friend really did
not want to go out and I am not the type of girl to ever leave
my friend for a man. Never in a million years. So, I ended up
just saying, "Hey, I think we're going to call it a night and
we're going to head out." And he was respectful of that 100%.
And I remember we just hugged goodbye and we left and that was
it. And so, we're going back to our Airbnb. walking home and
I get a DM from him and he said, "It was so nice meeting you.
I hope it's not the last time. Also, South Africa's happening.
I can see it." And the reason why he said that was because I
was telling him that I had wanted to go to South Africa for that
following Christmas and because my family was going to be traveling.
And he said, "I've always dreamt of going to South Africa." And
I jokingly was like, "Well, you're invited if you want to come."
And so whenever he made that comment to me in the DM, I was like,
"Okay, sure." I am not thinking anything of it right at this
point.
I whatever. like this guy lives 5,000 miles away from me. I'm
not thinking anything of it. So the next day we my friend goes
back to Germany and I go to Barcelona to meet up with some friends
and again I'm like posting throughout my trip and every time
I look at my phone it's like he's DMing me, messaging me and
he's continuing all of this and I'm just a little bit shocked
but also like >> at Vi at least at Vine Booms.
H you guys are so ADHD. It's crazy.
Like I'm ADHD, but you guys are so ADHD.
It's just a story, man. Just buckle in. What's the problem? What's
the problem, man? What's going on? >> Very interested still
at the same time. And he was remembering things that I told him
at dinner. Like I had told him that I was buy going to buy a
Chanel bag because I wanted to reward myself for working hard.
And he had messaged me and been like, "Hey, did you get your
Chanel bag?" And I was literally like drunk off sangrias in my
bikini and cover up in the Chanel store when I got that DM. and
I sent him a selfie and he said, "This is the best photo I've
ever seen." I just like felt like I could just be myself with
him already. And you know, we were just getting along and having
good conversation. So
again, he doesn't even have my phone number at this point. We
were literally just flirting through DMs. So I end up leaving
Barcelona the next day and I land and he sends me a message and
he said, "What are you doing this weekend? Do you want to go
to Ibisa?" And I saw the message and I was like, "What?" And
we will continue in part two.
>> The deception part two. >> Okay. So he sent me
this message saying you should come to IA. >> You're watching
this when it's two months old. What else should I be watching?
Quan, we already watched the aerodyite debate. She humiliates
herself. We've watched like everything. What else should I even
be watching? I thought, listen, I thought having a woman here
to comment on this for this like woman's story would be good.
I was like, "Oh, here's some content I didn't want to do like
by myself.
Hold on." Uh, hold on. So, what's the guy's name?
You see here? Danny Finkelstein. Danny. See if I can find uh
find something more queen speed here. >> Englishness and
Britishness
uh matters a lot, right? And preserving that culture matters
a lot. >> This is a Queenman stream. Now, we're going to
listen to British people talk. It's very easy to kind of go,
well, we're all just people and um there's nothing to any of
these cultural conservative inclinations. That is really easy
to do. Uh and if you do that, you solve all the intellectual
problems. It's all just terrible. All >> Do you watch live?
Did you watch that Nick Fentes interview with Piers Morgan? You
recognize this guy?
>> Uh no.
>> You didn't watch the Fuentes interview with Piers Morgan?
You didn't see that? >> I don't think so. No.
Oh, Piers basically got this guy to shoot a video for him where
he was like, "I think it's really offensive that you that you
make fun of the Holocaust. My mom died in the Holocaust, Nick
Fuentes. Why would you do this?" And it led to people making
um all kinds of fun of this guy. But it Oh, me. It it basically
all came down to this clip. Oh, also Fentes made fun of him for
being like, "Oh, what's this guy like?" Me mom me. Oh, wait.
I think >> he looks like a turtle.
He looks like a guy. Okay, dude. Dude, this is not funny. This
is not funny. >> My mom's a lampshade.
>> It's not cool.
That's not cool. That's not cool at all. This one's better. So,
oh, the story though is that basically his mom got in the Holocaust
and then his dad went to the Soviet Union and his dad was thrown
in a goolog like got pro persecuted by the Soviet Union as well.
So like Nick Fentes saying that he loves dictators really offended
this guy. >> Please buy my book. Please, please.
Oi, that's not very funny, mate.
died in the
mom died in the holly.
Me grandma died. Grandma died. Uncle died. My cat died. My dog
died. Everybody died. Nick,
not team Hitler. Whole family died.
I usually stop it at the list like Schindler's Line because it
just gets repetitive after that. >> Thoughts? Thoughts
on everybody mocking this poor old British guy who just was sad
that his mom got killed in the Holocaust? We're about to go do
another
>> Okay. Right. >> My mom's aid.
My cousin's a mattress. Yeah. My grandad
auntie's a suitcase. Yeah. I'm a diamond. I don't care. I don't
care. Yeah, mom's a lamb shade. She said my boy is a light in
the dark and ends. They call me lighty for short. Me dad's a
ner kind of smokes. They say the apple doesn't fall far from
the tree. I light up the
>> Okay. All right.
You get it? Do you get it? Do you get it? Do you get it?
>> Yeah. That was that was good.
>> Wow. Oh,
hold on. You don't know about anything? I'm trying to think of
like stuff that I can Dude, you don't know about anything.
Legal mindset just released a video on uh Ethan Klein's lawsuits.
Imagine with the Well, the original Hold on. Let me see if I
can find the clip of this.
Why did you write this article? I watched 12 hours of Nick Fuentes.
Dude, what what is the premise of this article? I watched 12
hours of Nick Fuentes. Do you think that makes you like an expert
in Nick Fuentes?
You you watch 12 hours.
You're like, I'm gonna write an article now. True.
>> Uh I think I think I've made my my stream watch more
of Nick Fentes just with this one clip like probably 12 hours
of just clip minimum. Okay. >> Massive epic song.
Epic. Last Friday
>> What's your opinion on Nick Fentes, Lav? >> I
think he's funny.
very funny.
>> But he's never been in love,
so he's >> uh I don't know if that's true.
>> I don't know if that's true. Might be bitter. I don't
know if the never been in love thing is true. >> I think
it's true. >> Okay. All right. I
watch 12 hours of super chats of super chats right now. Maybe.
Before each episode of America First with Nicholas J. Fuentes
begins. A surreal mix of images and video clips runs like a screen
saver for an unpredictable and seemingly eternal amount of time.
Gentle plains of swaying grass, trickling streams, the show's
logo flash across the stream or uh yeah, and the show's logo
flash across the screen. EDM kicks in. Psychedelic depictions
of Christian imagery, including Jesus's crucifixion come and
go. So do snippets of Fentes talking about, among other things,
borders, drag queens, and his faith. We want this century to
be the most Christian century in the history of the planet Earth.
>> What was that? That was anonymous with gifted sub. Thank
you very much.
>> I don't know how much longer we we got on the stream
here. Hold on. This is Even if I do that. We're at
that. I think we need three subs,
but whatever. I'm I'm reading this article. I'm in the zone.
I've become intimately familiar with these clips. Recently, I
spent 5 days as a regular Fentes viewer. Across five episodes
of the nightly broadcast, I watched the 27-year-old white supremacist
influencer speak into a microphone for just shy of 12 hours total.
The show is scheduled to air live on Rumble at 9:00 p.m. Central
time, but it rarely begins on time. Throughout the week, the
opening scenes played for at least 2 hours every night.
I am so happy that somebody laid this out as like the primary
criticism of Fentes, that he is the most unpredictable loser
who can never hit his start times ever.
You guys think it's bad here. I brought this up before. You guys
think it's bad here when I miss my start time by 30 minutes and
you complain. Nick misses his start time regularly for a 2-hour
show by 6 hours. Okay, that happens like all the time.
Okay, so you when you complain, it could be worse. All right.
Uh, throughout the week, the opening scenes played for at least
two hours every night, bouncing from clip to clip at random before
Fentes finally got started. I watched episodes the next morning,
and the first time I tuned in, I endured the intro sequence for
30 minutes before fast forwarding. Since Fentes appeared on Tucker
Carlson's podcast at the end of October, Republican leaders have
started to ask themselves just how much sway he has over the
party.
Quentes has built an army of fans who call themselves gropers
and his style of bigoted trolling, has become the lingua frana
of the young ascendant right. Each episode I watched garnered
at least 1 million views on Rumble. Wentes has attracted attention
for years, but as he's quick to remind his audience, he's operated
from the fringes, pounding on the doors of mainstream conservatism
and meeting fierce condemnation. Now Fuentes has momentum, and
based on what I saw, he's laying the groundwork to go even bigger.
went to the show is at
at the core of his political project. He first began live streaming
27 blah blah blah blah blah blah blah and I don't have a a login
for the Atlantic so [__] it.
Honestly, this is like every other article that's ever been written,
so who
Like it's just it's the same as every other article. I watched
for a week. Here's why I think this is really bad or fine or
guy doesn't know anything.
Let's do
the Hania bit. That's what I want to do.
Oh, that's not the right Hanania tweet, is it?
Oh, nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Hold on. Hania. Hania.
Hanania.
What do you think of Richard Hanania
Lav? Oh, wait. Wrong tweet. >> I have no idea who that
is.
>> he's a guy. Okay. Real dude. Real guy and a half.
>> Yeah. Let's see here. Tweet and the article. I wrote
about the heritage American debate. The question they can't answer.
If we agree with them, what should we do? As with woke, this
is about mediocre people wanting to invoke their identity in
order to gain honored status and shut down debate.
What do you think that about that, Lav? That if you care about
how long your family's been here, you basically are just like
trying to gain some uneared advantage. You familiar with the
heritage American thing, Lav? >> No, I I don't know about
what I'm
>> I'm out of >> see Carolyn Quan attacking me on
Twitter. Um, yeah, that sucks, but oh well. Yeah, I did see that.
I thought I retweeted your response. Did she say something bad
back to you? Or was it just the one response? He literally and
his way through my special needs high school, you hooknosed bastard.
That's just a queen viewer right there. That's just a classic
Queen of Viewer right there, isn't it? Followed by
Followed by a bunch of people I know who are themselves Queen
of Viewers. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
This one.
The memeification of Epstein has worked to obscure the horror
of his extensive crimes. This man to traffic children. He destroyed
countless lives and escaped accountability for years due to his
powerful network of friends, associates, and co-conspirators.
Oh, wait. This is what we're doing. Oh, that's Jimberly. Oh,
got him.
Fair enough. Uh, hold on. We're going to do this video. Obviously,
Asmin Gold reacting to what's in the Epstein files. I haven't
even seen what's all in there myself. Although, I will say from
what I have seen, I think I totally get it that people knew about
him being a and they were like, "Yeah, but
he's like the coolest hangout." Like I like literally hang out
with this guy. This guy every moment of this guy's life is awesome.
And like I don't I don't want to like literally when he goes
and does the kid thing I'm like gross. That's disgusting. I'm
out of here. But I do want to hang out when we like when we all
go and like lay on the beach and like drink we just drink and
chill and have an awesome time. Yeah. This guy's like so happy
all the time. He's so happy all the time. I've never seen this
guy Does this guy look sad anywhere? Does this guy ever look
sad a moment in his life? Right. I don't think so. Holy.
It's not healthy to be in a monogous relationship. The idea is
to build a harum. Damn. >> Oh my god. >> It's in
the official files. Like this is it. The justice.gov.
It's right there. So this is the guy. I mean again all of this
to Is this the same girl that that's there with him or not? I
don't know. So, there's him again, and that's him, I guess, on
on a plane. >> Thank God for Asmin Gold's commentary. This
is just groundbreaking stuff. I guess that's him like walking
up to a >> And that's him, I guess, on on a plane.
>> That's actually not him on a plane. That's him walking
up to a plane. He's getting so close there. Well done, Asmin
Gold. It was It was almost. >> And that's him, I guess,
on on a plane.
Oh, so close.
Okay. It's probably her sister. It could be her sister. You're
right about that. I don't even want to look at that. I just realized
what that is. >> I don't even want to look at that. I just
realized what that is.
That appears to be a child in his lap. That's weird, man. That's
really weird. >> I don't even want to look at that. I just
realized what that is.
>> It's disgust. >> This is This is why Asmin Gold
gets 1.6 Six million views in a day.
>> So, keep moving down. It's a kid. It's defin 100% a
kid. Like, guaranteed.
100%. Bro, there's no way that person's over 16. Piglet. No.
No. Piggy, not you,
Look at this.
Oh my god.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Okay. Um,
yeah. All right, let's go back. All right,
so this is somebody with their face blurred out. Another person's
very small. This one, it's just kind of hard to say.
Uh, no, it's not. That's definitely Glay Maxwell. That's 100%
Gay Maxwell. >> Hey, I don't really know.
>> Holy [__]
And this is some other girl that he's there with.
Creeps. Why are all the guys photos redacted? I don't know.
So, this is >> Be clear. I actually don't know that. I
actually don't know that. I literally just made a joke. >> Some
girl that's probably a victim. That's a random guy. Yeah. Why
is he getting redacted?
>> Yeah, I'm curious about that. Why? Yeah, why is >> they're
throwing his like VSCO filtered pictures on here, guys? Like
Instagram filters. He getting redacted.
>> Yeah, I'm curious about that, man.
Where would this money come from? I don't know. It's definitely
a teen. Yeah. I mean, it looks like she's not a I mean, I don't
know. I mean, it's it's very hard to judge something like that
by just looking at >> Wait, wait, wait, wait. Somebody
answered that. Where is this money? >> I mean, I don't
know. I mean, it it's very hard to
juice. That's little on the nose there, guys. Can you chill?
Can you keep it a little more casual than that? Like, what the
judge something like that by just looking at somebody's face
blocked out? But like I mean let's use a little bit of context
clues, right? Is this person underage? Probably, right? I mean
it's Jeffrey Epstein after all. So uh yeah, let's use some context
clues here.
It's a person next to Jeffrey Epstein. That is a child. That
is a child.
Uh
why go to as you get some real commentary? What did Chud say
about this? I think universally the call the call in this has
to be like man I get that this guy's bad but he lived a charmed
life
right Epste fumbled this just so he could kids damn damn I mean
he actually didn't fumble it wasn't he still with Gain Maxwell
when he got arrested
I don't think he fumbled it at all did he I don't think he fumbled
it at all
>> yeah I don't think there's a fumble
>> Joe Biden's son is on that file with pictures. I don't
see that at all. And uh depends on where the photos are taken.
I mean, it's Yeah. And this is also a public place, too, it seems
like. Right. And uh there's so many pictures of Clinton with
girls. Like so many. Well, if somebody wants to link me some
more of them, uh you know, like or my mod wants to link me some
more of them, I I can look at those, too, because like Yeah,
this is Yeah, I want to see some more of these, too. So, this
is the I've got five different PDFs full of photos. You've got
five different PDFs full of PDFs. Is that right? Okay. Well,
let's take a look at the next one.
Oh my god.
>> I don't know if that's like
>> this is just in Asia or something, >> I don't
know what they're wearing. It's some like tube top or something
like >> Just sending a document with a link. What the
That's weird. Yeah. Jesus Christ. Okay, let's go to the next
one. Let me actually I'm going to go ahead and open these off
stream just because some of them are
This isn't a good one.
The gang's all here. Oh no, not you,
>> Who could?
>> [__] dude.
>> Dude, it's crazy that it's just like Michael and Bill
Clinton.
And dude, Michael doesn't look real.
>> How do we just let this guy interact in society looking
like this? This is like This is actually completely horrifying.
We just let this guy. They're like, "Well, you made the music,
so you do get
It's like,
this guy, this guy would have been put in an asylum in any reasonable
society." But they're like, "Well, he did Thriller. We just got
to let him We got to let him go." Wow. Got to let this horror
show continue. It's from the Justice Department right here.
What a twist. I don't think this surprised anybody really. Also,
it's very hard to know like why this is happening, what the context
is of it. This is just one photo. I don't know who this person
is who has any idea, right? I mean, all three of these people
could have had >> I've heard that's that's somebody's kid,
right? Diana Ross's kid. I >> have no idea who this is.
It's obviously Oprah, Michael Jackson, and Bill Clinton. Like,
we all know this. So, >> wait. Literally false news trending
on Wait, what? Uh, this is Michael Jackson, Diana Ross' own children,
NYC, after his Apollo Theater performance for DNC fundraiser
alongside President Clinton. It's been on the internet since
2002.
Oh, it's literally not him. Yeah. Okay.
Mike Mike throwing blue steel at the camera right now.
It's like horrifying to look at. They faked that. I told you.
Okay. Damn.
Yeah. Who knows? Why does he look uncomfortable? I wonder why.
And uh yeah, I I I have always been like I I've been a huge fan
of Michael Jackson my whole life and I am still reserving whatever
delusional hope that I have.
>> Oh, you think this is put in here to make Clinton look
bad?
I mean, I think these are from the Epstein estate, are they not?
A lot of fakes out there.
Okay. That he actually wasn't a weirdo, right? And so, uh yeah,
that's not Oprah. It's not Oprah. Damn. It looked just like Oprah
to me. And uh I just I guess maybe I just kind of assumed it
was her. I didn't really look too close. So basically anyone
No, I don't think so, Nick. I think anybody who's not an explicitly
like known figure is blacked out. Like I think there are plenty
of civilians that are clearly adults that are blacked out. Like
tons of them in a bunch of pictures.
I I haven't seen a civilian that I've like I have no idea who
that is in any of these pictures yet as far as I can tell. But
let's see here. Okay. And here's another one here >> that
might [__] I mean, we'll see. We'll see what these
other ones, >> but like >> I don't know. >> Whatever
this one was, it was like basically every civilian is like blacked
>> Children are blacked out. Yeah, I'm sure children are
blacked out, but I'm telling you, I've seen a bunch of pictures
of people like around a table. Like there were pictures from
that bar mitzvah with Piglet and everybody's face is back is
blacked out. Like those aren't all kids.
>> No, maybe it's not. I mean, who the [__]
Diana Ross, I guess. >> Yeah. Well, I'm assuming all kids
are, but I'm saying it's not just people who are assumed to be
victims or kids. It's like a bunch of people who are probably
unrelated in any way. So, yeah. Wow. Uh, crazy photo to have.
What a reveal. Here's another good one. Yeah, we'll go we'll
go through these. Okay, don't worry about it. So, we've got this
one here. This is, I guess, her with two two D. Oh. Oh, wow.
Ah, that's great. Yeah, thanks a lot for including this one.
This is really useful. Amazing. Okay. Well, next. And so, this
is some of them are people who might actually be related but
are being covered up. just picking people off. >> Obviously
one of the victims right there. They're, you know, riding around
on horses. Okay. Well, next. >> And so this is obviously
one of the victims right there. They're >> Well, what why
are we saying it's obviously one of the
Bro, I watch Asminold and I'm like trying to chill and just look
at some cool Epcene photos.
Do you know that that's a
What's up, Wes? How's it going?
Why don't you just pull the files up yourself? Cuz I'm feeling
lazy and I can just hit play on this and then Asmin Gold does
all my work for me. >> You know, riding around on horses,
>> And also, I bounce off of Asmin Gold. What's up, Wes?
How's it going,
>> man? I think that there has to be those files useless
as Yeah, the Gawons. I >> in here. Save me. >> I
really think that there needs to be a conversation about the
fact that they said they didn't have these files.
whenever they said they didn't have
don't know if they said they didn't have the They said they didn't
have the client list.
>> Pretty sure that's what they said. >> Well, why?
Yeah. Like what the if if this was here, then how did you not
know that they don't exist? Exactly. Like this is And to me,
like obviously it's good that the files were were revealed, but
think about it like this. So >> I don't ever think about
stopping and getting mad at the cookies. I think about the cookie
factory that makes the cookies. And yes, obviously it's good.
God, are all cookie analogies like totally
broken for me now? >> You're just a fragment of my past
that needs
Wes, you're hurting me. >> Good that some of this information
is now out and it's made public. But the problem we're reviewing
the pictures, we're reviewing Asmin Gold reviewing the pictures.
Level of laziness never thought possible.
>> So level of laziness never before thought possible.
>> I did go blonde, Wes.
I tried to include you on. You just don't know anything. You
can't do any entertaining content because you know
>> [__] horrifying. Jesus. The person that
get from the public classic BP join the stream. Join the stream.
Blonde. I look hot. I look so good. Blonde. You got shower first.
Holy. That's going to take forever. It's already 3:00 a.m.
>> You look like the most basic [__] ever.
That's literally not true. And you're being mean. >> Okay.
is still in a position of power. There's still like I mean you
don't know what you don't know. So there's no way for us to be
certain about what uh what's still being uh reserved, what's
being withheld, what's not being shown. Like and so this is the
problem that I have is that the trust is broken and people don't
know. Like why is it that you said you didn't have anything and
there were no files, but now there's a law and there's a bunch
of files. There's 300,000 pages of files. That's crazy. They
said there were no more suspects. What are those redacted names
>> Well, it's not even about that. Was there more information
that everybody should have known about? Yes. Did they have that
information? Yes. Did they say that there wasn't any information?
Yes. They lied.
It's that simple. Whether you think that it's conclusive, it
proves anything. It was not about that. It's about whether it
existed at all. And it clearly does. So that's what they should
get fired. It should be fired like at the least. Like at at the
very very very very least.
Is Wes hopping on the stream or is he just gonna throw a couple
chats and then peel
>> He said he was gonna shower. >> So frustrating
for me to see that >> forever. He has to clean in between
his
>> That is going to take a long time. >> Information
that's hidden that nobody will know about. Exactly. Yeah. >> Although
Wes I think Wes is skinny now. I think Wes is like full-blown
skinny
>> Is he? Let's see. >> That means he's like a sharp.
>> His skin's hanging off of him like turkey meat.
>> Why? How would you say that?
>> It's true, >> dude. I swear to God, what is wrong
with Kick 16 hours ago stream from West and see what he looks
like now? >> I had five star chocolate. >> Question
is, I can get you on. All right. All you got to do is hit me
up. We'd be surprised.
>> Elf bald. >> What is this? >> Turn your
wager on sports in the past year. I was banned.
Just send me a message. There's no exception. Like, it doesn't
matter what the question is. I can get you on. All right. All
you got to do is hit me up. >> Space Ghost has donated
174 subs to your
>> Wow, that's true. >> He's your [__]
oiler, dude. And he wants a piece. Send that guy a picture of
your body. >> Top 10 lifetime. He's not even in the top
10 lifetime.
>> You really are the greatest. Hey guys, kiss me. How
about that? >> Big fatty. Look at that little piggy. >> Sit
in my mouth. >> Little hog. Punch me in the mouth. Wes
looks like Winnie the Pooh. You're right. And your butthole's
the honey and I'm coming for it. >> He does look like Winnie
the Poo. >> Oh, Kirby Badger's a girl and she hit me with
an emote.
Wes looks like Winnie. You I'll give someone a bond if they give
me a song.
>> he literally does look like Winnie the Pooh. That's
cute. >> Oh, what were we talking about this >> Are
Loner Box and Hassan fighting? >> Oh, yeah. They were doing
these days.
>> is he is he defending Destiny anymore or he's over it?
>> Uh, no. He's still defending Destiny pretty strenuously.
>> Is he?
>> Yeah. Big fan. Yeah. I don't really get along with him
anymore because of it. I put a wedge in the friendship. >> Darn.
G Willickers. >> That federal guy has some interesting
ideas. Shut up and listen. As age is just a number at Israel.
Israel's official ex account 1.8 million followers. Age is just
a number. What was this talking about? It's like it's a football
player or something, isn't it?
Post deleted.
Who's ready for an AMA? What was this? Age is just a Dude, people
don't like this Israel. People don't like this Israel account,
man. I have >> a gas cramp in my tummy. I'm dying. I'm
dying. I'm dying. I'm dying. I'm dying. >> That's rough.
That's trust has been destroyed. Cash actually said they have
no credible Dude, I I have no ability to maintain a coherent
thought right now. So, we're we're in trouble. All right.
Between both of us, >> I'm dying.
>> Did Carolyn respond to the meme back? Because I think
Queen and meme back. She respond to that.
>> Everybody Everybody's just doing the the Everybody's
posting
sick Epsteits in response to Carolyn Quan. It's disgusting.
actually disgusting. Like I think we can all agree
that if Destiny was a with this kind of swag,
he never would have gotten in trouble, right?
I think everybody can agree on that. Like universally, no.
>> Oh, sorry. I forgot Destiny's not actually didn't mean
to say that.
It's a joke, though. Hold on. We got We got another another Epsteit.
bad things. It's a lot of bad things that they wish and wish
and wish and wish and they wishing on me. Yeah.
Hey. Hey. She say, "Do you love me?" I tell her only partly.
I only love my bed and my mama. I'm sorry. 50. I even got it
tatted on me. 81. They bring the crashes to the party and you
know me.
Turn the
03.
me. Imagine if I met the broken.
I feel like this is in the photos by the way.
Like this exact person is in the
>> I can't do this on my own.
Someone watching it close. Yep. Close. I' been scarlet. Hey.
Hey. M down this go. Yeah. Wait, I go hard on Southside
You get a response back? No response back.
People are very offended right
Count based in UK. Oh, I'm sure. I'm sure. Loser.
Well, technically he is a dual citizen. Okay. Israel/UK.
Dual citizen. Dual loyalty.
Why he sweeps for Epstein? Okay. Saw asset.
Hate to see it. The edits go
>> You be thinking it's
actually. Or is that a big meme? No, he's actually
>> there's so many
tears down.
Oh, these hills, they burn so bright. Oh, these hills, they bring
me life.
Okay. Why Why is there just a picture of Stephen Hawking in here?
I do remember Stephen Hawking getting connected. I do remember
that. I remember at the time just thinking like, "Okay, just
come on, man." Like, what was he even doing? What was he even
What was he even doing there, man?
I know he was on the flight logs. I do remember him getting connected.
Yeah, I
I keep a cage, but I can't control it. Cuz if I let him out,
break me down. Why won't somebody
>> Okay. All right. All right. All right, dude. There's
just so many.
>> That turbo. >> You can get the biggest back in
the store if you want it. I gave them a drip. They suck it up.
I got them on. I bought a new paddic. I had a white so I tone
them. Taking the drugs. I'm going to be up until the morning.
>> Wes Wes, we need your help to comment on these sick
epig.
How about you stop leaving the Discord, you fat,
the [__] is wrong with you? It's There it is. It
just got linked. He just got linked. Discord.gg/jsstk.
He just doesn't want to get doxed.
I get it. I get it. I get it. I get it. Not everybody can stand
on business. So [__] it up, man. >> I would
love to get
I don't care where I go. Long as I get
That person is clearly young by the way. That is another one.
Another one.
>> I found it hard. It's hard to find.
>> What is good my
What's up, Wes? How's it going? >> How's it going?
>> That's okay.
What's up, King?
>> Wes, I took three benadryil. Do you think I'm gonna
die? I >> think you're going to turn into a a bee. >> Why
did your mic Did you just change your mic? >> Your mic
just went super quiet. What the
>> uh nope. Same mic. It's always been in the same place
it always has been. Didn't move. It didn't change it.
>> You're
okay. You're trolling. >> It's fine. >> I'm literally
not trolling. It's the same mic I use for stream.
>> Okay. All right. It's fine. >> You think this
is a bit You think the mic's a bit
>> uh You're going like quiet then loud then quiet. >> How
do I What is is input profile? Should I go voice isolation studio
or
>> I think Discord does some that
up sound >> They always my my mic on Discord never sounds
good. It literally for seven years I've always had like professional
mics. They never sounded good in Discord. I don't know why. I've
tried so many I never never have understood it. >> Is there
like >> every other program?
>> I bet they're trying to do some kind of
I bet they're trying to do some kind of like voice like volume
normalization.
>> Yeah, I bet it like everything
>> that anything that looks like it's
>> Yeah, it's quiet. >> Input volume is at 100%.
Uh, input sens sensitivities max. Voice processing crisp standard
or none. Let's go. None. Turn off automatic gain control.
Turn off advanced voice activ.
All right. What the is good.
>> uh You just got really really quiet. But the I think
the gang control thing is probably what was you. >> I got
really quiet even though the gang control off. That makes so
much.
>> Yeah. I Yeah. I don't know.
It's literally been Yeah, forever. I literally I have no idea.
Sometimes it's just totally
>> Uh, can you like lean all the way? Dude, you are so
quiet now. Whatever. Turn the game control thing back off >> in
front of my face like I'm a podcaster. Does that make it any
better? >> This is >> That makes it way better. >> Is
in front of my face. I can't see anything. I'm blinded by the
microphone. But if it helps your godamn ears, fine, >> It
does. It really does. Whatever I can do to help you, little guy.
>> Thank you.
>> Why is Discord so dog [__] Sounds perfect
through OBS. Stream is fine. Like, what the how is this build
a $20 billion company and can't get goddamn microphones to work
correctly?
>> I don't think it's $20 billion company, but yeah, I
don't know. >> I think it is actually. >> It's the
one thing they have to work. It's the one thing they have to
make work and they can't make it work. >> It's the only
thing that would make it make sense. Like that's where all the
money is is right. the ability to communicate with your friends.
Discord's worth 15 billion. Yeah. >> Nice, dude. 15 billion.
Can't get a microphone working. >> Hey, I had a question
because you're the guy who just looks at everything and doesn't
do anything yourself. Can you
>> Did anything actually come out of these files this time
>> or is there is it just more? >> I'm literally
just watching I'm literally speaking of just watching and not
doing anything myself. Literally just watching Azim Gold flick
through all these these pictures. I I don't think anything tangible
came out. No, I didn't go through them. I had other stuff I was
doing. Um, >> all I saw there was one who had like a three-year-old
next to him and he was smiling devilishly. Did you see that
>> I've seen a couple that are like, "Yeah, it's clearly
somebody of questionable age." He had like some dude >> some
like kid in his lap and he was like smiling and the kid's face
was blacked >> Kind of weird. >> Did he ever weigh
in on what's his age group? Cuz right there's all those classes
of like the younger the worst type [__] Was he the
worst the lowest class or was he a high class? >> I think
the stuff I think high class
like like as in you mean like older
>> legally? Yeah, I think it was like that. >> Yeah,
if you're like a child like a four-year-old like you're you know
that's a lot lot worse than a 15-year-old but then he keeps having
pictures with a four-year-old and so it's I'm like you'd assume
the one the billionaires would be the worst of the worst though,
right? This guy's like sacrificing kids after he f some type
>> Yeah, probably.
That's why you get an island, right? So you can go do that. Go
do that on the island.
>> I think there's no laws out there. I think that's how
that work. >> You don't need an island just to [__]
the kids, right? You can get away the kids anywhere. >> No,
but sacrifice the children. Yeah. And get rid of their bodies.
Yeah. You need a island. >> Yeah. You need an island. The
true weight of it I feel like has not dawned on anyone because
like it literally is like hundreds of kids have been like murdered
big by this human being and all these rich political people and
then people are just like OH THERE'S NO PROOF LIKE THERE'S NO
CONCRETE proof we're we're covering faces but like can we NOT
TALK ABOUT IT THAT LIKE EVERY RICH white person is
that doesn't seem like a a net positive in my opinion. It's like
a kind of a smaller subset of whiteish people though, right?
>> Yeah. Well, the rich
>> Yeah. L Are you
>> uh 14%.
>> Thank god you're poor.
>> I know. >> Just if we just took all the money
away, they'd stop the kids because the initial is the the hunt
for the gold. >> Once they have the gold, then they're
like, I'm bored. I need to the kids. >> Oh, you didn't
see that? You didn't see Candace Owens go off on uh on Ben Shapiro,
did you?
>> She basically called like contract people said they
are trying to like basically enslave all the she she like went
so she went like hardcore researchbased anti-semitism like the
oldest anti-semitic tropes. >> The classics >> Ben
Shapiro. >> Yeah. when like not just the classics, not
like the ones everybody knows, like ones people don't know >> really
how it's their gold. Yeah. Just
>> No, no, no. Not new ammo. It's like old and it it comes
out through all the other things. But she's like
>> talking like World War II like was using to get people
to turn it against the
>> But it's like
conspiracy these people cuz they hate Christians and they want
to make sure that they can like enslave the Christians. All the
black people, black people were totally enslaved by and like
sold in the slave trade. It was mostly not even white people.
They tried to turn us against white people. It's actually all
>> true. Did even exist in America during the slave trade
era? >> Yeah, they're the slavers. Um,
>> No, the I listen
I'm pretty sure there's like uh there were people
I don't know. I I actually don't know because I I realize I've
heard this all from anti-semitic sources. So I I was like, "Oh,
I've heard it from multiple places." Then I'm like, "Wait, they're
all like anti-Semitic places." So maybe >> But I thought
it was like the people who actually went and enslaved people
and like had the ships, made all the money.
>> Yeah. I think >> I don't want to enslave black
people cuz they've dealt with enough, >> but like we need
to enslave somebody. Cuz if you truly think about it, I've looked
up like inflation rates. They're
>> Slaves would go.
>> That's okay. Hey, what if we took all the Indians like
teleamp teleol scammers? You get caught doing that, you get sold
into slavery.
>> Yeah, like India has like a cast system. They've got
a whole cast of people that they just sell into slavery
>> I want to buy one. I want to buy a couple, but I'm banning
all curry eating.
I can't stand the smell, dude. I uh I had a real racous moment.
First time I've had it in like 10 years the other day. Uh, I
like, you know, I live in Thailand and this is a huge place for
Indian tourism and they're the worst of the worst. They're not
like American Indians. They're like the lowest pass Indians that
could, you know, save up for 10 years to come. Four of them try
to one lady at one time type of [__] Like real real
subhuman [__] And I walked past a group of six of
them. Uh, and it was to the point where like you're 100 feet
away and you start smelling it. And I got so tilted by the smell
I screamed hard dogs at them. And then I was taken aback by myself.
I was so mad. I thought of like the most hateful slur I could
think of that had nothing to do with their race and just screamed
it at them. And then I got away with it because they didn't understand
what I was saying because who the [__] calls an Indian
a hard dog, >> Yeah. I don't Yeah, that's uh totally and
then everybody clapped or >> No, this this actually happened.
This is not a this is not a joke. It was outside the 7-Eleven
right next to my house. It was six Indian dudes. I screamed hard
dogs at them and kept walking and got on the train. This is a
real story. I hate Indian tourists, dude. They if you have never
been to Asia, you don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about. All right, Indians is people are great people. Indian
tourists, mog the out of the Chinese. Okay, everyone says Chinese
the worst tourist. You've never been to [__] Asia
long enough, dude. Go to poor Asia and then tell me which uh
tourists are the absolute worst. It's bar none the Indians. They
like are the only people scamming, the only people smelling like
[__] the only people never bathing, the only people
like trying to everyone on their prices. They're the only [__]
people doing it. And it's ALL IT'S LIKE 95% OF THEM. Kandreel
says, "Tide people do hate Indians." Wow. >> Everyone does.
If you talk to any girl haters like what's the one race or group
you won't with? I I've done this like on rail streams like without
it every it's I'm batting 100%. It's always India because they
everyone has the same experiences with the Indian tourists here
because like they're the people you never met before, right?
These people don't get to go to America. They don't have enough
money. So all these racist Instagram memes and people just make
up their racism because of Instagram is bull. you experience
like a straight low cast Indian tourist in like Southeast Asia
and then you'll finally get where the Instagram memes come from.
Like I'm not the person LIKE AMERICAN INDIANS ARE PEOPLE like
you know with a little bit of money, a little bit of class. Good.
Do your thing.
>> Anyway, I'm a racist.
>> Yeah, I got that. That's >> right. I feel like
um Indians are uh like the safe racist choice right now. And
I think you're a coward
if you think that uh that's the only race you can be >> I'm
not racist towards Indian and it's not the only one. They're
just the worst. And it's not the races.
Who's your like specific favorite races like >> I don't
have a tier list for races. It's truly just groups of people.
>> Like I've met Indians all over the world I have no problem
with. It's low cast poor Indian tourists that just ruin the experience
for everyone else. But I don't like see an Indian person. I get
mad. If I smell an Indian person, I get
>> But that that's just normal.
It's kind of the point. I haven't eaten Indian food in like four
years. Since the first time I came to Thailand, I have not eaten
Indian food since. I can't smell the smell without getting enraged.
Cuz you're just having like a good night and then you smell it
and then you look over and then they're doing
no one else does making fools of themselves being cheap,
>> I've got like a way lower standard for my racism where
it's like not lower, it's like different, but I know I'm racist
still. I love the smell of curry
unless it's coming from somebody's like presence in which case
it didn't like bother me viscerally disgusting.
>> BUT IT THAT DIDN'T BOTHER ME. IT WAS LIKE IT WAS A LITTLE
BIT UNCOMFORTABLE. But it's like now I've attached the negative
experiences with the smell. You know, like when you get sick
and you get food diversion, like if you eat Taco Bell and you
get sick, even if Taco Bell didn't make you sick, your brain
will think, "Oh, I hate Taco Bell." It's the exact same thing.
But you've watched an Indian tourist do so many things and you
smell it the whole time that you smell it and then you're like
I just get I can't even >> I've got that
I think the the universal experience is if you get way too hammered
on some kind of alcohol and you like tie that >> you'll
hate it for the rest of your
>> exactly. That's food aversion but with alcohol it's
a real psychological thing. It's the same except it's smell aversion
people. What are the trope for Chinese being? That's what everyone
says. As you ask that question, 99% of people say Chinese is
the worst tourist. I've never seen this. I've never had bad experience
with Chinese people and I've been like countries.
The only people have ever issues rules. >> You you little
[__]
>> No, but dude, I've been everywhere. >> I'm guessing
just Thailand doesn't have rules. If you go to go to like Britain
and you'll see they're all lining up and all the Chinese people
are like, "Why is that line there? I'm going to go to the
>> Yeah, I see what you a little
>> maybe you go somewhere where there's like a lot of order
and but that's probably not most places where
>> you don't see them in like Japan and you don't see the
Indians or the Chinese very much or you just can't tell the difference
maybe that's >> that's cuz they don't let them in. I went
to Korea recently. Hard. Don't recommend. Place sucks balls.
>> I can imagine. >> You had a Johnny Somali?
>> No, it's just nothing there was cool. Like the only
thing is cool is food. I've been to every Asian country now besides
China and like Korea is the only one I was like this place is
mid as
there's no cool tourist. It's just like Chinese America. It's
the same [__] as us. There's no nothing sticks out
to it. You guys tourist spots in Korea.
>> Exactly, dude. I went to like five different cities.
I spent over like over a month in Korea and I was bored the whole
time.
The there's no like real bars. It's all KTV which is the gayish.
Imagine paying a woman to drink with you and then just like talk
to her. You're too shy to finger. Like grow up you. And if you
can't speak Korean, you can't interact.
There's no cool night life. There's no cool day life.
It's just boring as everyone just works and is miserable. Somehow
Japan rocked, but those people are more miserable and work more.
I don't get it. I think it's because they resorted to alcoholism.
Koreans resorted to sitting in their home and off. >> Hold
on, hold on. It's like, do you think it has to do with the Christianity
there that like Japan becomes awesome through like total degeneracy,
but then Korea is like very Christian in
>> You think there's something like that? >> We got
put in the most up situations. At one point, I literally found
a place that you hung out with someone and then for the last
10 minutes they put on like speed like super fast like anime
Korean music and try to jerk you off as fast as possible. Like
literally like imagine uh like one of those racing animes, but
the car is your and that even was like still not fun. Like I'
I went to the depths of hell in Korea and could not find anything
worth doing. I don't know what I'm venting by the way. Thanks
for being my psychologist. Y you're about to get the craziest
[__] of your life. >> Dude, I wish I filmed
it. It was the most surreal experience ever cuz you hang out
for 45 minutes and just talk and they do like some show take
off the and then just go and then put on THIS AND THEY'RE LIKE
YOU HAVE 10 MINUTES TO COME AND THEY GO and they literally like
get mug burn to try to make
I couldn't get harder. Literally I'm getting soft tug. She's
just pulling my little worm for five minutes until I just like
give up. Get off me please. I can't do this.
And everybody clapped. >> You should stop having prostitutes.
I >> I don't have prostitutes. Not anymore.
>> Okay. Well, that's good.
>> That's the old past. I've kind of Hookers are only fun
for like a certain amount of time and then the couple
>> Yeah. I get I got a good year of hooking in me and then
it's just like >> it's boring. You got to have emotional
connection once you have enough carnal. It's like I like speed
ran all the hoe phases and the Tinder phases, all the [__]
that you have. I just speed ran that and now I'm just like, "Okay,
well that's good. Let's settle down." >> I don't understand
how Wes doesn't get STDs. Like, how? You don't understand how
he doesn't get STDs from getting hand jobs? He just told a hand
job story. Like, I don't understand this guy doesn't get STDs.
>> And I've had my first time I came back, I had three
cuz I was just
now like you weren't faking the test. Have you told people the
truth yet or >> THAT WAS NOT [__] THAT'S not
true. I don't have a dude. You know what's up? My girlfriend
literally didn't know for like 6 months. She thought I had a
this whole time. Turns like I'm like how are you this stupid?
Why are you still having sex with me raw if you think I have?
She's like I don't know. I assume we'd be together forever. And
I'm like
stupid.
Why?
Anyway, but yeah. No, that's not real. I don't have >> That's
scary. >> I know. Well, I apparently I did check. Uh I
looked it up though. Like having a only sucks if you live in
America cuz the treatment there's like multiple thousand dollars
a month. Here it's like 60 bucks a month forever and you just
have zero viral load. Never can transmit it. Never turns into
AIDS.
>> So they've got a pretty basic lady probably don't care.
>> WELL, NO. I LOOKED IT UP AFTER my lady boy experience.
I was like what if I get a dude?
Everyone was safe. They were on they I made them show me they
were on prep. There was condom. Like I made sure, but
>> Could that be like a cheaper version of Ompic cuz you
just get like AIDS and then you like let it wear. >> No,
because you have to get to get the weight loss, dumb ass. The
medicine keeps your HIV from turning. >> Shut up. I know
how works. I was trying to meme like I did. You ruined it. >> Oh,
okay. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
What you have your [__] dead? I don't think there's
It's like a You know, once you get to level two, it's the boss
is unbeatable. Level one, the boss is super easy. Level two is
instant death every
>> I don't Yeah, I don't think there's a way around. Once
it turns from V to S, you're cooked, buddy. >> Yeah, sure.
>> What are you doing in life these days? What happened
to you? I hate just what you look like now. You went from unique
and had a sparkle in your eye and now you just look like every
boring 4,000 follower Instagram I've ever seen. >> What's
going on, man? >> I think that's true. I think I'm prettier
than I've ever been personally. >> That's cool. I'm glad
you have self-confidence, but I'm just telling you like it is,
>> right? Uh, are you >> sure is, you know, your
social media numbers are doing better. >> Based off my
profile photo, you >> Yeah, you're a woman. Of course,
you're going to put a your a profile of a photo of yourself that
you think is very attractive. So, I'm assuming this is your go-to
look now. And I'm saying that's like a vapid boring Instagram
girl now. >> Well, this is >> the satanic influence.
>> That was my Halloween costume.
Um,
I'm married love to Goon. Goonar Gu
to go.
>> I forgot.
>> WAIT, WAIT, I KNOW WHO GUNNAR IS. WAIT, if I'm I maybe
misunderstand the timeline. Didn't you like you were still dating
the Ridge Walllet guy and then you started Gunnar?
Yeah, we had an open relationship and then I I fell in love with
>> Dipped on Ridge Wallet and then married the Gucc. >> I
did. Yeah.
you [__] suck.
>> I can't wait till you get divorced, bro. It's going
to be a good arab will be
>> No, I'm I'm >> How long you been with?
>> I mean, we've been together for three years, but we've
been married for almost a year. How >> How old are you?
and 27.
>> West West. Did you miss the arc of Lav
exposing the fact that Gooner Ice Boseidon like repeatedly over
a long period of time? >> He Kimmy.
>> Yeah. Kimmy. >> Is that where their initial breakup
came from? Was the Gooner thing?
>> Well, they've broken up like a billion times, but they're
>> the most recent one. And >> yeah, because she
found out to him. She'd lied to Ice Poseidon about >> So
wait, you're now married to a guy and you say you're domestic,
but he chicks,
>> No, this was years and years ago. This is like three
years ago. Four years ago. >> Oh, now you're in a committed
do like domestic monogous relationship.
>> Can we find Can we find the video of it? It was so brutal.
You have no idea. Like literally Ice is sitting there trying
to [__] them and Lav is laughing about how Goonar
next to like a half empty Popeye's bucket of chicken >> like
on his floor mattress.
>> It's uh it's pretty
>> Kimmy or Lab.
>> why do you know that much detail?
>> Why would Gunnar know that much detail? Gunnar was talking
about story. >> Yeah. How do you know that?
>> They're married. >> We're married. Yeah. What?
>> Yeah, but you don't know. seems like a crazy amount
of detail to know the Popeye's bucket and everything like you
got a full on wait. They had like a whole rivalry though, Wes,
you don't you missed it. They had like a whole rivalry
>> so Lab would have wanted to know all the details so
they do better for bikini in the future.
>> Well, that's not necessarily true, but um he was trying
to me at the same time and I was like, "No, you
>> No goon. Oh, >> and then he got his life together.
He >> was [__] Kimmy. He was trying to get
me to fly out to him and I was like, "No, you like don't even
have a mattress." Like, "No, I'm not going to." >> So,
how did he get his life together? How did he go from no life
together to your to him? >> Uh, he I he wanted me, so he
got his life together. Yeah. >> This is not a good arc.
I don't like this arc. >> No, I
have a good job. Interesting things. I mean, that's great for
you, but it's for interesting. It's not interesting. I come here
for chaos and destruction >> dreaming basically. >> I'm
glad that you're happy in life as a human being, but I hate that
things are going good for you
>> for the context of the internet.
>> All right. >> A though. I'm still doing my thing.
I'm still trolling. >> Stop. You're You're role playing
now. You're code switching to try to act cool. All right. We
get it. What? We get it. Trad wife. >> I'm not We do Oh,
we do together. Yeah.
>> Be on camera with his big hog. >> And for what?
You have you have a million dollar. >> WAIT, IS THAT LAUGH?
>> WELL, that's me.
>> What the
>> Hold on. SOME CONTEXT. >> LOOKING LIKE THE GOLEM.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> SOME CONTEXT. >> HOW FAR HAVE WE FALLEN FROM GRACE?
>> WEARING no makeup. And I had a miscarriage
DAY. JESUS CHRIST. >> THAT DAY.
>> So [__] was like [__] was not
sweet that
>> You had a miscarriage worse than ever.
>> So should I drop the chest or not? >> The clip.
>> Do you have a kid? >> YOU HAVE A YOU HAVE A MILLION.
>> I have I had a miscarriage. I just said >> Yeah,
I know. But you guys click on the
>> Click on the presentation. >> Like I don't know.
I'm watching the the
All right. We don't have to watch it right now, but just I'm
playing. >> So, should I drop the chest or not? >> And
for what? You have a You have a million dollars and he [__]
your girlfriend on a mattress with no
>> What was it for? >> Well, I'm not sure.
>> I'm not sure where you're pulling that from, but >> Oh,
no. >> Like what? >> One HP.
>> One Hoseidon.
>> Oh, yeah. Zirka heads. Okay. Dude, I don't even think
you know what she was up to. >> Oh, good one. All right.
>> He still doesn't die. >> If that's not it, it
could be the wrong >> Anonymous tip $3.33.
Never forget Ice took Kimmy back after Gona pounded her with
his 9 in. Dude, you are pathetic.
>> Oh, good one.
>> It's hard to watch [__] like this, dude.
Cuz like in real life, you can just not be on thousand people
watching you being like just getting your soul ripped out, man.
But he just can't.
>> And that's Yeah. And that's like the community he built
too, right? Like he built that community that will rip him apart
for it. Like >> Well, also >> at this point he did
not know cuz she did not tell him. So he was being invited to
all his events. He was being Tim was being invited to all of
Ice's
>> How long before this was like the big breakup, the most
recent one? >> This is the most recent >> I think
this was the most recent big >> Oh, this is the start of
it is when Gunnar had said that.
>> Okay. And then she >> technically Lav said it.
Just to be clear, Lav was the one who said it because Ice Beside
was like trying to with them during the scavenger hunt and Lav
like lost her temper and >> went off the rails.
I just want to say that because I don't know if Goonar ever rebuilds
a bridge with ice. I just wanted the record that >> I don't
think so. >> You didn't bring it up.
>> Yeah. I don't think he can rebuild that
>> I don't think so. >> Unfortunately, started going
into
>> [__] that chick. She's mega hot,
I don't care.
>> The best comment or the best Yeah. The best comment
I heard from Gunnar during that was like, uh, I think he told
Ice that he used his girlfriend for friction was like the way
he put it. Oh my god.
>> He said he called her his personal [__]
machine.
>> Pretty brutal. >> All right, I got to go. I love
you. I'm sorry. Some my shorty just walked in.
>> Love you. Bye. >> Better now. >> They're
just mad that they're losing. >> Now I got to watch >> and
they have to go after my girlfriend who is not involved with
this at all. >> Messages.
Screenshot them all.
>> What? Careful.
This is a crazy arc. This is some funny [__] You
want me to play the song? Uh, I played the song a bunch. I don't
want to get gratuitous with it. Okay.
I've already got one. >> Did you see Did you see >> emasculated
psychopath trying to ruin my life? I don't need a second one.
What's
>> Did you see the recent stuff with Kimmy? How she DM'd
Westside Mike?
>> No.
and asked, "Dude,
when he was uh when Ice like last week was doing his like movie
reveal, Westside Mike showed up and was like, "Kimmy DM'd me
and the DM was like
she wanted to learn how to paint for painting lessons."
But it's like Westside Mike is like I It was just weird. And
then and then uh Ice was like I told I told her to DM him. I
I did like totally coping. It was brutal. Like she's still doing
it. It's gnarly. It's really gnarly. >> Uh where's the
video clips of this? >> I don't
I think his VOD's still up. Tim's VOD's still up. I don't remember.
I saw those DMs. She wasn't flirting.
Dude,
you don't you might be too to realize that she wasn't going to
immediately flirt with a with the first message. Asking him for
painting lessons is like enough, I think, to be like, "Okay,
dude. What? You're asking Westside Mike? Your your fiance is
a millionaire. You live in Austin, which is a city of
and you're DMing Westside Mike. West side like it's Poseidon.
See here.
>> And then when he went up to her to like
>> to talk to her at the event, she was very very nervous.
Westside Mike is handsome. Yes. Just brutal.
>> At Kimmy, come on. Call me. Let's go have a drink. >> Kimmy,
let's go have a drink.
>> Something you've never known. You're We don't have opinions.
You could have an opinion with me. Come out. Have a
>> I think they're perfect. >> I'm trying to find
this. >> I hope they work it out. I hope Kimmy [__]
Maybe she's just stupid. I don't >> Let me try to find
this Gooner VOD of
>> What's some tips for pulling my life together and marrying
a grade beef like yourself? Um, be funny. Jesus Christ said that
what a weirdo
>> crisp lettuce. Shocking.
>> Um,
to be honest,
I just do I might just do the move where I go actually, we're
way over time for the stream and I'm going to go do something
else. I think I think that's the move here. What do you want
to do, Lav? If you want to if you want me to keep the stream
running, I'll run the stream for like another 30 minutes. >> We
could do that. Zena told me about this as if it was going down
and showed me the DMs. Yeah, Zena obviously that's her friend.
Why? If you're DMing, if you're I have had no reason to DM any
man
the whole time I've been with my husband for any reason. For
what reason would she try to DM Westside Mike? Like you have
to think about like why
like why she would do if any man DMs me at all. I'm giving like
one word answers
like I'm not going like that's
weird to do. It's weird to do.
>> I agree. White Sharia. White Sharia
>> Like if you if you had a if you had a girlfriend JST
and she was DMing another creator who like was known for being
kind of a ladies man
and she was like, "Do you have painting tips?" What would you
do? I don't know. >> You'd be like, "Dude, why are you
doing this? This is weird." >> Probably probably depend
on the exact situation as it went down in that exact >> You
wouldn't be like, "You're a disgusting." But you'd be like, "Dude,
what are you doing?" Like, "Why are you doing this?" You could
get painting lessons anywhere. >> I think if I were Ice,
I wouldn't want my girlfriend just DMing random dudes from those
communities. I do think that could get weird.
>> About what?
>> I'm going to West Six. If you guys want to collab, >> we're
going to get
is reacting.
>> That's a big deal.
>> I I I think he's waiting for you to turn around and
walk away with him. >> I'll see this [__] Let's
collab at West Six. I'm going to get hosed. >> Something
you've never had.
>> Kimy's over there. You said where is she? Why? >> She
DM me on Discord. Tell us about you. Want to see it?
>> I mean, I don't care, >> dude. You want to see
it? Let's go in the living room real quick. >> Why are
you trying to be weird, bro? Come with me. This is I'm not going
in the house. I don't >> Oh god.
>> Oh, I forgot about the picture of um of Ice's room or
sorry, of Gooner's room,
>> Isn't that brutal? She's getting her face in this room.
>> just brutal. Like, oh my god. I remember he was trying
to get me to fly out when his room looked like this. There's
no way.
>> You see my blanket fort? >> I don't know if we're
allowed to go the
>> I'm not going in that house. I was never told that I
can go in there. >> Such a [__] >> I'm
not going in there. They never said that I could.
>> You've gotten too many alarms with police. You're scared
of life now. You want to make money like Nick White and do no
content. I get it. I get it, bro. But listen, I saved nothing
for People
always say this about Nick White. Does Nick White, As far as
I know, Nick White doesn't make any money. I thought he had like
all of I thought he just like bought it super hard and he got
all of his KCIP [__] taken away. This not the >> I
don't know anything about Nick White. I don't know a thing about
him except for Action Man's girlfriend that like sucked him off
or something. >> This is like a lot of work to go through
just to do this one bit. The rat and goons room comes in comes
in and says it was very hard to rumage through the room during
that era.
That's that's a that's an insane amount of that's an insane length
to go to just for a bit. >> Swim back. I never >> that's
like that's definitely re by the >> Westside Mike saving
the night. >> He's a killer of creativity
and once you're comfortable you're Nick. >> No, it's a
guy who uh No, no, no. I've talked to the rat in Goon's room.
>> That's not re
Nick White, >> don't have a double chin at 28 years >> Holy
[__] >> Don't do that.
>> Then drive Lamborghinis,
>> dude. He'll >> Let's see this. >> Either
way, we both
>> for lessons. >> Is he a good painter? At least
>> he's apparently he's a fantastic artist.
>> I'm going to go give a real girl a
>> German. It's a German folktale.
>> Oh. Uh-oh.
>> You want a wife? >> Guy does not want the land.
>> Yay. Thank you. >> Listen, I'm going to teach
you how to
>> like Rembrandt. >> Oh, no. >> Or like Michelangelo.
>> He He is Adriana.
>> You're telling me that? Oh, this is hilarious, too.
She was like trying to politic with Adriana because me and Adri
are friends. Kimmy does this thing where she like she really
like
>> she's like a [__] She's like a total >> just
a just a total. It's like crazy where she's like a total [__]
Yeah, I get it. >> It's [__] crazy.
It's like It's like It's like we're 15. It's crazy.
>> Yeah. Trying to convince everybody that you actually
suck.
You're actually like the worst person. >> It's like It's
like control tactics. It's like It's weird. She was doing that
even before I I said anything. It's weird. She's just weird.
She's like tried to get a bunch of like women out of the circle
because of her insecurity with with Paul.
It's like just weird. She's just weird.
>> It's I've never I've never been around women like that.
And then uh
I didn't even know realize that they were real, but they are.
>> I believe it. >> Regina George
>> Mean Girls.
Turn around. >> When he's in a room with a girl who's like
very pretty, she acts very strange. >> Wow. I've never
heard of women doing that before. >> It's I have never
been around anyone like that before like the Twitch scene, but
I've always been around like dyes and artists and I I guess I've
just Yeah, it's just weird. It's weird to be
>> Okay. I feel like that's not true, but I'm going to
just let it go. That one slide by.
>> I feel like you would definitely know. I feel like this
is describing every
I feel like this is like how women are socially conditioned is
to constantly like form these kinds of hierarchies. Yeah, I feel
like it is. But >> this type of woman, like this type of
girl who has like no hobbies or interests. Yeah, definitely.
>> Jack or >> No, I don't know. I just >> Do
you want a beer? >> I mean, no. We're just having a conversation.
Christmas Eve.
>> Adri so cute. >> Oh, Adriana wants him gone. Adriana
just tried to toss this guy. >> How will he handle that
comment? >> We're going to have one real quick before I
leave.
>> You Adriana off. We're just having a conversation. Yeah,
now I'm having conversation. FUNNY HOW THAT WORKS.
>> DANG, I didn't realize that was your
I just wanted like tips on like
I get so many weirdos texting you >> and I've been gone
for a year so I'm like who is
>> and you don't have like a check mark. >> Well
I I was just like I >> it'd be funny if you >> Wait,
do people even get a check mark on Discord or is he just making
up? >> Like I was just like uh I just like wanted tips
on painting.
I feel like now It's weird because he's very very
>> he's very very clearly flirting now and so and he's
reading something into that painting stuff. So the longer she's
like not saying anything
uh I I think this is like uh like she's like into this or was
looking for this. It's weird that she's letting it happen
she's on camera. You wouldn't expect that. I don't think >> Westside
mic's got really tall.
>> I think Jimmy's like 51. So Westside Mike's going to
be like 63 >> DMing Isha. Holy
>> Yeah, I have a Canvas. So I like I >> Is it or
canvas?
>> Um it's it's
>> Why are you filming me? >> Cuz you said you're
the content, right? >> And I can't like just >> Shuy
Shuy knows the content. Shuy knows the content. Hold on. I don't
even understand painting tips. Like what? Like what do you mean
painting tips? Like what?
>> Like what do you even get the like get a canvas and
get paint?
>> Wait, when is Shuy filming this part? Hold on.
Shimmy Shu is like filming this before or is it all after?
Here's this part. Here it is right here. YouTube tutorial. Kimmy's
actually not allowed to use the internet. >> Um, yeah.
I was making like a like >> I didn't realize that was your
discord. >> I just wanted like tips on like
>> but I think so many weirdos text me >> and I've
been gone for a year. >> So I'm like
>> Shuy Shuy has the nose for content that I wondered how
this got recorded. It's just Shuy over here like oh this is this
is trouble
chat saying follow this follow this.
>> He does whatever his chat tells him to do.
Well,
>> listen. Was it Kimmy's Was it Kimmy's nose job? Ice
again. This guy's direct. Kimmy's nose job is secretly directing
all of the drama in this sphere. Okay. >> Kimmy's nose
job is doing a terrific
>> That person is crazy >> causing drama all over
the place. Kimmy's nose job >> and its consequences
been a disaster for the entire CX sphere. Okay. I I was just
like I um got a canvas and I was like drawing and I was like,
"Oh, I want to paint." But I like I know not >> actual
canvas. >> Yeah, I have a canvas. So I like I just >> Is
it or canvas?
>> Um it's it's canvas.
>> Why are you filming me?
>> you Hey, dude. That smile. He knows exactly why he's
getting filmed. Why are you filming me? Why are you breaking
this weird? Yeah, you know exactly why I'm filming this. >> You
said you're the content. You you know exactly what it is.
Apologize. Maybe we should not face it. >> That's what
I'm
kind of rude. >> You look amazing.
>> Sorry. Things were just now winding
>> It was great.
>> I just got back from Miami. Look at how much content
I am.
>> I I'm not joking. I do get the sense that she doesn't
want to be flirted with and she's too polite to say it.
I do actually get that feeling.
>> her man is literally right there.
>> Like, yeah, of course not. >> Very much.
>> How good do I look? I think >> you look really
good.
>> I told Paul to buy some >> Kimmy making Ice look
like a Once again,
>> dude. Shuy's TTS is funny as Hold on. Let me switch
my title up real quick. God damn, dude. Godamn.
Why you do that?
>> It's actually up that she's over here instead of watching
Ice's premiere a little bit. Okay. Ice worked so hard on this
and she's talking to this drunk who's flirting with >> this
Lambo to like nice restaurants. >> Not great. >> I
don't know. >> Well, she had to talk to Adrian in a dark
corner.
>> look it guys, I'm all the confidence.
>> Did that cause a problem? >> Can you guys make
a clip?
>> Dead talk quieter. Do you actually use those calie boots
for anything? For your head when I stomp on >> Zeus, I
love him. >> I adore Zeus.
>> Well, I just bought him. >> What part of Zeus
do you really like the best? Is it the rampant? >> He's
just
so funny. >> Insane racism. >> I mean, sure. He's
the leader of the white race. >> Yeah, I that's not true.
And if it was, I would myself as a white person. >> Zeus
is good in 20 years. Yeah, I know. That's why I love him.
Zeus is great.
When me and uh Tim were fighting,
Zeus called him and was like, "What the are you doing, dude?
Go get your girl." It was really funny. >> Amazing.
Uh, hey, I hope you're doing well. I am wanting to try and learn
painting. I know you've done it for many years and are super
talented. I was wondering if you have any tips for beginners
or where to start. Who's this? Got him. Wait, why is Kriger here's
the message? As far as I know, there's no further communication
between them until this premiere.
Yeah, that's a cold that's a cold reach out though
until this premiere. What do you mean? There was no more reach
out before until this career. This is less than
>> this is what like a week. It was like a
>> Who is this is who he asked back. Okay.
>> Because he's the only artist she can learn from. Yeah,
that's what I'm saying. Like
>> Hey, how did Ice end up over here? He's the content
>> and then Ice walks over. Okay. >> I miss white.
I missed Ice >> coming over.
>> Well, I just bought him.
>> can you hear what they're saying?
>> You need some boots, bro.
>> I'm not a cowboy though. Sorry. >> Well, I'm not
either.
>> Pulled up. >> How you going to
shave? Almost pulled aggro right there, bro. Pulled up. Ice didn't
like that little comment from Shuy at all.
>> You need some boots, bro.
>> I'm not a cowboy though. Sorry. >> Well, I'm not
either.
>> But listen up. >> How you >> They talk about
nothing for a second. >> You are not Westside Mike. I made
you two paintings.
>> And you support [__] Sam.
>> Uh, you made a really >> Exactly. But you know
that's not me.
>> I'm not going to publicly be like, "Oh yeah, I'm banned
Westside."
>> But like
what's interesting here is that he's describing how Westside
Mike was ousted because he was after he said that he was wants
to his daughter someday. He made like a really horrible joke
and got banned from kick and everyone was like this guy.
>> His own daughter said
>> yes but he doesn't have a daughter. He just made a bad
joke.
>> but he got out. He got asked >> weird when Kick
does that >> and nobody talked to him anymore. And Ice
is really is talking about how like nobody wants to talk to him.
So then for him to switch up minutes like 30 minutes later after
this and be like, "Oh, I said I said I I told her to DM him is
like because literally right now he's describing like I don't
want to talk to you. You're a weirdo." like
>> well he hasn't quite said that yet but >> I can't
>> see what he's going to say. I said that >> to
the rest of his life. >> Maybe I just don't remember
like a year ago >> I said that saying he doesn't want to
be associate. He just said he didn't want to be associated. >> Oh
yeah. No, no, no, no. He's saying I couldn't have helped you.
I I wasn't going to be around you. So I think it's close to what
you were saying. Like hey I can't >> earlier said verbatim
I don't want to be associated with that. Like he literally said
that like a minute ago. You broke my heart, bro. Cuz I was growing.
You knew that. >> Yeah. Well, don't say >> Zirka
says it. >> Clab says it. >> Clab's gonna get banned,
>> Wait, Clab did just get banned, didn't
>> Didn't Clvicular like just get banned? It wasn't for
these jokes, was it?
How hard is it to not joke about kids
on Instagram? Oh, I see. >> I guarantee it. >> He
does not say she like that. >> He does though. I mean,
glad. I mean, well, you said it's crazy. >> It was, but
the reality is if it was crazy, I would be in jail.
>> You know what's
shooting a girl? All these people are
>> That's also crazy. >> And then you support him.
That's nuts to
>> I know he's your buddy. >> Yeah, but it was like
an Indian girl. >> But what do you gain from if you read
>> is what racist people like Ice Poseidon would think?
Okay. Not me. Were you That's more funny than that.
>> I It was cuz you brought about money >> right
away >> and not Do you want to watch them?
>> I got one.
>> I love how we are always the content.
>> Dude, bro, >> I just had to come see what you
guys are talking about >> off stream.
I know the best spots in Austin and I know you don't,
>> if Tim ever DM'd a member of the opposite asking for
like tips or lessons,
I'd be so >> Okay. Um,
I mean, it could make sense. This guy, I can tell that this
I can't believe that this guy could be a good artist to be honest
with you, just from how he's talking right now. >> He doesn't
seem like the type, but he he is actually. He This is like some
clout chasing like moment right here where he's like trying to
get in with Ice Beside but also with Ice Boseidon. He knows exactly
why Ice Boseidon's staring daggers at him right now. Okay. Trying
to poke Guy's trying to poke Westside Mike's eyes out with his
nose right now. It's like what he's imagining happening. >> But
sometimes those people I mean I'm that way and I'm an artist.
>> You're what way?
I'm I'm I do I'm like a not a similar personality type, but
these type of people can be fantastic artists.
>> What What type of people? What are you
>> Like what do you mean?
>> Well, I'm saying that he was just flirting with Kimmy
and now he's like, I know the best places in Austin. We should
hang out sometime, man. We could be we could be bros again.
>> Yeah. No, he's he's But he's trolling. This whole thing
is a troll.
You think
>> He sounds drunk to me. >> Is back and I would
love >> I came here to make amends to be honest. >> He's
100% drunk. He is not just like
>> Dude, just the community. I would love for you guys
to
all the that I said. >> You should be trying to make a
mental
>> fact. I I listen. I'm a sensitive artist. I said the
wrong things. I understand it was out of pocket. I don't have
children. I don't have a wife. I'm a bachelor. I live with >> I'm
hearing a quaver in his voice like he's like
I Dude,
>> I think that >> this guy is literally intoxicated.
>> Uh I think he's just has like brain damage or something.
He's like sort of just weird. He's a weird He's an odd guy. This
is like a really long conversation though. But I think to sum
to summarize it, they like they talk about nothing for a while
and then he says that I think he's about to say that Ice has
never been with a hot girl before
and Ice gets mad and is like, "You don't think Kimmy's hot?"
And then
I forget what happens,
but it's like way too long of a What is this time stamp? >> This
is a time stamp when stuff like actually pops off. It's an hour.
>> How old are you? >> I'm 32. Can't be a master.
>> I was already married.
>> We got divorced last year. >> Yeah. So, shut the
[__] up. Who are you talking about? >> So,
what do you mean you're back? >> I'm I I love live streaming.
I love
>> but it's just Twitch is not the >> All right,
we'll send in your appeal. >> Dude, I'm
500 times. I have >> and the cobras are there as like Ice
Poseidon's
like security guard. So gay. >> This guy did get unbanned
though, right? He just got unbanned.
>> mother got unbanned. >> We do a video together.
>> [__] did she go? >> Like I watched
I gave them all away. >> Oh no.
>> I gave Kim one and then Paul me.
>> No, I didn't know that was your
I met him and I said, "We're going to go make content and we're
going to save nothing for the swim back." >> Listen to
this. Save nothing for the swim back.
>> Comfort is the killer of creativity.
>> Dude, this guy is like I'm sorry if this guy's not drunk.
If he's like half crying, there's no way. >> Once you're
comfortable, >> No, that's just He has like an RFK >> Once
you're comfortable, you're Gary Davis. I mean, both those people
make 50K a month. >> Guess what? Money doesn't matter.
>> Do you want to be Gary Davis?
>> No, listen. >> Money. No, listen. Money doesn't
matter. >> Gary has 10 homes. >> No, listen. Money
doesn't matter. >> You're a bachelor at 32 and Gary has
10 >> Bachelor. You have never even seen my
>> You said you're a bachelor. I'm just >> means
single.
>> dude. Bachelor means single. Listen,
>> comfort is the killer of
>> Oh, his community actually made 20 edits of the movie.
He chose his five favorites and one to show at the >> Creativity
once you're comfortable. >> Oh, I never got my Ethereum
from this guy. I forgot I won one of the I won one of the scavenger
hunt things, the location picking thing, and I never messaged
them to get my money. I think I think Legacy was hitting them
up a lot for the money, and they weren't giving him anyway. So,
not created worth chasing down. >> You will never have
a legacy in this
>> Money doesn't matter. Everybody in Miami has money.
>> Are you [__] kidding me? >> They pretend.
>> Go to Miami art basel.
>> Everybody just take >> Dude, this guy is not trolling.
I'm sorry. Nope. >> 0% chance. >> You've never seen
a 10 in away. So, we're not >> You've never seen a 10 in
your life. >> Over talking his show. >> A 10 out
of 10 chick >> cuz you've never dated one. >> All right.
All right. So, >> what's your point? You're saying Kim's
>> No. I didn't know that was your >> All right.
>> He didn't say it was his girlfriend. Wait, what? How
did he Dude? Okay. >> Are you stupid?
>> About what? >> Just chill. >> About what?
I chill out. >> How was I? I thought you were
>> Yeah. Okay. So, you're [__]
>> bro. When have you ever announced >> He's like
crying.
>> When have you ever announced that was >> He has
an RF voice.
I mean, you clearly don't watch my streams or >> I do.
>> All right. Well, then you I mean, I've been What are
you talking about? We've been dating for like eight years. >> How
do you know everything about me and all that, but you don't know
that? >> What do you mean? How do How would I assume that
he's dating?
>> He's a
gunk gardeners in the background. The cub rubs, right? >> I
mean, you if I was the million, you
>> Yeah. I didn't I don't even recognize this guy. I recognize
this guy, though.
>> He's But he's a loyal ass guy. >> I didn't know
that. >> He is. You know when you
uh get old my favorite
tell us about it >> as somebody who's actually as somebody
who's actually able to many of my time
>> yeah I'm sure so many [__]
>> why why
>> dude this guy has such low self-confidence for no reason
>> for no reason his girlfriend is so rough to watch no
it's so [__] rough to
[__] he has every reason to be confident in himself
and like that is so much worse than any I can't even think of
a worse thing to say guys pressing you saying you don't [__]
you're like I lots of [__] actually I [__]
so many stage mage thank you so much for the five gifted merry
Christmas buddy thank you thank you thank you appreciate it
somebody calls you like a loser says you the worst thing you
can do is go no I all the time I all the time.
>> It's just embarrassing. >> I I can tell you it
gets old. >> One week ago, >> you want to You have
that fantasy cuz
>> I so much that actually got old. >> You don't
know how old it is.
>> you don't know that because
>> the only reason you know that is cuz you have more capital
than I do.
>> So you could fly from a visa. I could do that too, but
not every week.
>> Right. So that's the difference. >> Yeah, I'm
sure you're flying from a visa. Sure. >> I definitely could.
>> And I told you that since the beginning I met you, bro.
>> You don't think I have money?
>> Fun fact about a lot of people at a >> be This
guy absolutely strikes me. He's like a trust fund kid though.
Like if I had to him absolutely
>> like he probably has money but he's
>> raves for the record. That's usually where druggies
and alcoholics go to Aziza. So, >> thank you very much
for the raid Io. Thank you. Thank you. >> Like saying that
flexing you a lot of then aza really isn't that impressive. >> Well,
then you don't need kick and you're fine. You've got from aa
hobby for me. >> You do your thing. >> But the viewers
wanted me to come say hello. I did it. I said I'll be here for
2 hours. I'm going to go do my thing. >> I would love to
find a way to make amends. I don't think it's going to
>> with who? You got to make a mental kick. >> Exactly.
As >> this guy's like Zerka without any mystique, without
any like spice. This guy's like unseasoned Zirka. There's very
There's like a lot of blandness to >> He's brain damage.
Zirka.
>> Yeah. Well, >> nothing to do with >> TBI.
Let's not take Let's Yeah, let's not take too much. Yeah, Zirka,
but smaller in every sense. >> Or you.
>> if they can see this, if they watch your >> all
right, guys. Well, >> I'm a well-groomed guy. I'm a nice
guy.
>> I would love to be back on that platform, even though
the KPPP went
>> It did go down. >> It definitely did go down.
>> Not if you're not a viewer.
>> You know how much I made right off the
>> You want to know more?
>> You want to know? Hold this out. I don't really care.
>> BJ Turner
beer open real quick. >> You probably made like what? 5K.
>> Two. Every two hours. >> You said how much? >> I
said 5K. >> No.
5K. >> He had it for like two weeks. >> 10,000 a
week. >> He had it for like two weeks, right? >> We
were making 10,000. >> He could have made that. >> Remember
I told you that No, that's what you wanted. In what world? >> We
were making 10K a week. The max I made was 7K after the trip
in one week.
>> That's impressive. And then I completely
>> Wait, what?
I made 10K a week. The most I ever made in a week was 7K.
If this guy is not drunk, then yeah, it's just brain damage.
Like actual brain damage. >> Yes. Literally, I wasn't being
funny. from Thanksgiving >> on Monday.
>> I just blacked out and I said the dumbest amount. >> I
mean, I know that's not true. So, >> it's 100% true. >> You
do not make seven. How much did you >> 900 subs. Nobody
has that. >> He's talking about after he got the KCIP during
the rat race. So,
>> What is he talking about? >> He got KCIP mid rat
race. >> So, he's making >> So, he's talking about
after it ended when he was doing desktop. >> 900 subs.
>> in a week, >> I swear to God, we could go back
to my >> Impress. I mean, impressive.
>> You guys can do this anywhere. We're here at the film
fest.
>> I suggested we should step over there so we're not being
>> We can take this outside. >> I mean, what you
said was rude as >> Let's step uh into the road >> about
Kimberly, but >> what did you say? >> Well, I didn't
know. How is that? >> I'm going to assume.
>> Wait, is that He's asking, so it's fine. >> It's
fine. I can't I can't >> Of course Glink is committed to
whatever he has going on,
>> Yo, Paul, >> I don't know anything about this
guy. I've just seen him have like some of the most anti-content
moments I've ever
>> It's very funny. He goes to the film festival. It's
his house. HOW DID HE GET ALL OF HIS MONEY? WHERE DOES HIS money
come from? Sage Mage, thank you so much for another five gifted.
Appreciate it, dude. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Huge W. >> Oh, he's asking us to step away so that we're
not being loud. >> Merry Christmas, man. Happy you're having
a good leadup to Christmas here. Four days away. Four more sleep
since Christmas Day. >> I'll go back to watch it. >> Well,
I know Glink is a YouTuber. I just thought he like I thought
he fell off super hard. >> I remember he had his stupid
festival where he had Curtis Yarvin
and then like it was like maybe it was pretty bad,
>> Like straight up. The love of the art. >> What
did you say about Kimberly?
>> I didn't know they were dating. >> That's cap
as [__] >> I thought I thought you came to
their home, bro. >> They've been dating for years. >> They
weren't dating when I showed up. They've been dating for years.
No, when I was around, they were not
>> Oh, we need this guy in our chat. Reptilian believer
says, "West Mike is working for Reptilian Alien Templar Knight
Messic FBI cops."
>> Why is that guy not in here? Go find me this chatter.
I need this chatter on my
Reptilian believer.
>> So, what's up? You and him are plotting. >> Is
that Darius?
>> What the [__]
>> Wait, this guy knows Dar. Okay, so this guy didn't know
Kimmy was dating Ice, but he knew he knows Darius is dating Zena.
Yeah. Shut the [__] up, bro.
Get the out of here.
>> He's [__] put your foot off me again.
>> Chris Angel. >> Chris Angel. I don't understand,
bro. >> So, what's up? You and him are fighting over Zena.
>> Nah, you're shaking. >> What is bro talking about?
>> Why instigating?
>> Why is he instigating? Why do you think he's instigating,
bro? It's a contest. >> Cuz he's desperate for views. >> Wait,
are you mad that you got somebody in prison?
Like you feel any remorse?
>> What are you talking about, bro? >> Zena, you
sent her to prison. >> She did not go to prison.
>> I mean, you don't feel any remorse as a
>> I don't know what you're talking about,
>> Bro,
you don't >> like, did you just come here to say anything
that you think
>> Darius is doing like an anime bit? Darius is trying
to be an anime character right now. Like they giggle and stuff
like
>> under someone's skin like you just came here to like
press. Like I don't understand. You're just thinking of everything
you can. >> Honestly, that's W content. >> That's
what I'm saying. You literally have a video of you putting somebody
in jail for touching your shoulder. >> You literally have
a video you talking about kid on the internet. So what's worse?
Him putting somebody [__]
>> Yeah, a daughter.
But the fact that you as a man spoke who gives a [__]
fantasy that's fantasy. >> That's not my fantasy. >> You're
a weirdo, bro. >> He might have put Zen in jail, but you're
a reality. >> You have fantasies. You're a >> Why
are you talking to me? >> Cuz I'm confronting about the
truth. You want to paint pictures. >> I don't have to [__]
walk away. Who the [__] are you, bro? I'm not your
>> He keeps saying that. >> Yeah, cuz I'm not your
>> I'm a man, bro. I'm not your [__] >> Make
some content. He is actually happy to make content. >> I'm
happy to make content. However you want to make content, I'm
happy to make content, bro. >> Bro, you >> they are
they are guning ice.
>> I don't think Darius is. Darius was like, "No, I got
it. He's making >> I've been around longer than you, bro.
I know exactly your
streams. >> I know your dungeon. I wasn't in the with burger."
>> No, the bedroom streams.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait. >> Did he ask Glink about the lights festival?
Oh, >> I think >> Hold on. Where's the Where's the
glink bit here? >> Remember
I was very quiet. >> I came to see cuz the light Oh my
god. >> Oh, never mind. That's not Glink. >> Well,
I was in a >> I thought Glink was there for a second
>> but it also also I'm >> How far How far do we
have to go to find the next bit here? >> Nothing about
Mondo. You were >> who just said you have a fantasy of
being with your 12-year-old daughter. You should be curb stomped
right now. >> What are you going to do about it?
>> Wait, what? So, you're not denying that? >> No,
I'm not denying that. >> How about this? It's real. It's
so real, >> It's so real. It's a reality. And I'm still
not in jail. I love it. I love being Jeffrey Epste. >> Why
would you?
>> Uh, the bit's only funny once and I saw it for the first
time with Max, so it's not funny again. >> What are you
saying, bro? Yeah, >> bro. It's >> You should be
trying to reformulate. >> I'm getting DMs on Discord from
girls I've never met now. >> What the
>> How do you know they're actual women
>> Bro, you're not even have a DM. >> She's messaging
me. >> That's Discord. >> Yeah, that's what I just
said. >> Okay, open it. >> What did she say? >> Well,
why do you care? >> I heard someone here was calling me
a >> I apologize. >> I accept your I hope your hand
feels >> And my ribs.
>> and your ribs. >> Damn, dude. What happened? I'm
not going to apologize. >> Yeah, kind of [__]
You guys are dude, look at your face. >> West submissive.
>> It is legacy. That was Darius's girlfriend, wasn't it?
>> Wasn't that Darius's girlfriend who just walked over?
The one he stole from Princess or whatever.
>> I forget her name.
[__] I forget her name. Was her name? It's like,
okay, nobody Dayquil. Thank you. Thank you. >> What happened?
I'm not going to >> Yeah, kind of [__] submissive.
You guys are dude, look at your face, bro.
Look at my face, bro. That's like >> west submissive,
dude. >> Is it? >> That's Wes.
That's your chick. >> All right. Go grab her hand.
>> He talks to catfish bots. He lies about
Talks to catfish bots. He lies about
>> This is basically if you're ever in a late night VC
with Quean, okay, like playing video games or something. This
is like the only commentary he does over any video.
We should kill this guy. This is like the the only thing he says
whenever I'm like watching some some piece of media. He hears
something he doesn't like. We should kill this guy right now.
>> You're ever in a VC with Quebin like 10 people in it.
You're watching a video. That's like the only comment he makes
the whole time. >> He talks to catfish bots. He lies about
>> I swear to God, at some point there will be a point.
Okay, at some point in time it will happen where Quimman's watching
a video of himself in some VC with like a group of people and
he will he will actually say this guy about himself.
>> I've been talking to you. >> It will happen right
here >> No, no, no. Hold on. >> I'm not I don't mean
to interrupt, but is the dude with long hair are you guys like
together?
>> They're having a baby.
>> Pregnant with his baby. >> Ter's hair is so funny.
I'm not I don't mean to interrupt, but is the dude with long
hair. Are you guys like >> actual Wolverine haircut?
>> They're having a baby.
>> Pregnant with his baby.
>> With Legacy,
>> Oh, yeah. I guess that's his name. I don't know. >> Yeah.
Yeah. I'm pregnant with his child. >> Okay. Okay.
>> Months and this is what you've turned into, huh? This
is just normal, dude. What are you talking about? God damn it.
Dearorn, Michigan, man. This is normal, dude. I'm being racist,
man. >> No, just like insane, man. >> All right,
I think we're good to go to wherever this clip is.
It's >> pull it back just a little bit.
>> How would I not acknowledge the chat? >> Well,
I guess we
>> You're just a [__] weirdoaged
in it, not someone else.
>> It's all right. I mean, mostly
record the content. No problem. Thank you for having this. Yeah,
for sure. I want to do more things. I want to >> My goal
is really
>> PP Thompson just tipped $20. Nobody gives a [__]
>> You're doing God's work. >> I hope one day to
meet you drinking cheap Lambrusco wine in the Giant Hills overlooking
Rome. >> Thank you so much PP Thompson. Really appreciate
it, buddy. 20 big ones. Super appreciated. Thank you so much.
really just to bring >> one day. I don't know if it'll
be the Jean Colo Hills, but it'll be somewhere in Italy. Okay.
>> The real life scene
>> together with the online platforms in a way that's natural.
>> I know so many streamers that make crazy money and have
a lot of viewers >> and I know so many people
>> shut THE UP GLINK. SHUT THE UP GLINK. There's actual
content. I'm also I'm also screaming at my house in the middle
of the night like almost in morning. >> Great bands when
they make cool films and they don't really have any of that.
>> Like shut THE UP LIKE SHUT the up. No, wait. J, please
peep earlier when Glink spawns in on the street. Wait, what?
>> 9 to five jobs.
>> So I just >> buy me a clip of it or something.
I can link the VOD. Buy me a clip of it, but I'm going to keep
watching this.
You want to like if there's cool things that cross over,
you know?
>> No, don't shoot this guy. Sorry. Sorry. >> I don't
care. Get away from me. >> What are you talking about?
>> Like, you're just a weirdo.
>> Dude, I get it. >> He was saying some crazy. >> I
know. I know. Like, I don't want to like I don't want to talk
to you, bro. >> But, dude, the camera's on me. >> Congratulations.
I hope you enjoy it. >> I do. >> Enjoy your your
five your five minutes here. But I'm saying this
whatever hopping in there.
>> I love it. >> Love to see it. Chat,
>> you about to get CS right boss man? >> I'm good.
Yeah. >> Yeah, we're good. >> I literally >> You're
about to get CX text message saying, "Can you show me how to
paint a picture?" And then you use that you use that as a way
>> and we're live on >> You're saying weird [__]
>> I mean, I don't know. I'm not watching your stream,
but all these other guys are telling me
two people need to be banned from the platform just for the sake
of improving the content on everyone else's stream.
I never support deplatforming, but these two could be deplatformed
and all IRL streams would only get better. >> Weird [__]
What did he say? De, what do you say? >> He said, uh, he
was reading messages in his chat. He the messages messages. >> The
messages said Kimmy wants to meet you. He's like, "Oh, yeah,
she can meet me at a lounge in Six Street, you know, tell her
to pull up to like a >> Why would I not acknowledge the
chat?" >> Well, I guess we >> But you think she's
actually saying >> because I donated five subs. >> Oh,
congratulations. On on what? Twitch. >> All right. Well,
I'm going to make sure you're banned on Twitch. >> All
right. >> Because I'm banned on Twitch. >> All right.
>> And you're filming me. I'm not that >> and I'm
filming you and you're banned on kick, but I'm not going to get
banned. >> No, I know. I love it.
>> You're just an [__] dude. I don't know what
else to say. You're just an
>> bro. I was being >> I was being nice and I was
like, >> what's you should reach out to Westside >> dude.
Paul,
bro, what is Paul doing? Why Why are you fighting You're fighting
with a complete
This guy is Yeah, clearly like mentally compromised. I I actually
don't know why he's fighting with this guy. >> And then
you're
going to use that as like a way to try to be an >> What?
What was about it? >> Is there is doing like a Who's the
explosion guy from Bokohhiro Academia?
>> That's who he looks like right now. Is Bakugo right?
That's who he looks like. >> Uh just saying weird in your
stream, >> dude. I literally She was standing with your
girlfriend. >> What's up? >> Hit me in my DMs, dog.
That's
>> Shut up. not even a part of this. >> Listen, man.
>> Let me say this. >> You She was talking to your
girlfriend.
>> Your girlfriend.
>> Who was talking to my girlfriend? >> Kimmy was
talking to my girlfriend. >> So, the chat said,
>> Uh, W. Shuy. >> Wait, you just saw that, right?
>> You saw that? >> Your girlfriend.
Dude, [__] He's like watching Chicken Andy trying
to get trying to comprehend whatever this Westside M guy is saying.
He looks down at the booth. >> Who was talking to my girlfriend?
>> Timmy was talking to my girlfriend. >> Yeah, he
said. >> So, the chat said, "Go give her one of your mango
beers." So, I did. And I asked her, I got your message about
painting lessons.
>> What? What the [__] are you talking >> See
what I'm saying? No one knows the context. It's >> because
you're saying weird about the >> You didn't even You don't
even know about it. >> I do. I told her to message you.
You >> No, but you didn't tell her to.
>> Yeah. After watching Oh, listen. We watched the whole
thing just to get to hear.
I don't believe that. I fully believe that Ice is the kind of
person with so little self-confidence that he's going to say
that and know that Kimmy will feel bad about this and back him
up. Even though that is a complete lie. >> Say that in
the message. I don't know. So, I got to put this
she wanted to learn how to paint and I would >> I told
her to message you.
>> You told her to message the guy the who you don't like.
>> Who's like more attractive than you?
>> Learn how to paint. >> Teach her to pay. >> All
right. So, why do you come on stream and say weird then? >> What's
weird?
>> Just like the >> You're trying to make you don't
have an example. That's what's >> I mean, I'm not watching
your stupid stream. I don't know.
Oh, this is pathetic. Oh,
Ice is so much He could be so much better than this. There's
no reason to have this fragile an ego. Like say all kinds of
like what? I don't know. I don't watch your stream.
Shut up. What are you What the are you talking about?
>> I don't I don't watch your You said really bad things,
but I don't watch you and I don't care. But I also told her to
message you,
>> Yeah, exactly,
I can I can obviously tell that you're saying weird in your stream
like what? >> I don't know. I'm not watching your >> Bro,
why are you trying to act dumb like you weren't trying to like
say like you'll meet her and >> like literally this Westside
Ma is a total and the only thing that turns this into a clip
or makes it anything is just Ice having this insane insecure
reaction to him. That's it. That's all that's happening here.
Like this guy has said nothing of he's he's been totally worthless
the entire time he's been on camera and Ice is just getting worked
up over nothing. >> Give me that. Give me that. Like what
do you want? I can't
>> read the chats.
>> You don't think I >> I mean you're just playing
stupid. >> You do that too, bro. >> You're just Okay,
cool. You're just >> You're playing stupid. I don't care.
>> I've only said positive things about you >> the
day I met you. >> Stop recording this. >> I mean,
that was the only I don't know. Remember when I w >> Bro,
Ice needs to
take all of his money, put it in a trust until he can't access
that he can't access until he turns like 55 and then he needs
to start over and approach this as a guy who needs to make money
cuz he's got all these people who know they can make money off
of him and be by being around him and none of them are committed
to the content. This guy's like actually got one point and it's
that none of these people want to actually make funny content.
All these people are like, "Stop recording this. This is weird.
Why are you Why are you doing this stuff? Shut up.
You [__] serious?
This This is literally the This is literally the only kind of
content anyone around this wants to watch is personal drama between
these streamers. That's literally what everyone's here for. They're
not here for a film festival. They're here for whatever the this
is. >> Sorry. Go ahead. >> Yeah.
What Ice needed to do in this situation is just like punch Westside
Mike in the face and like tell Kimmy that she was a and leave
her. That would have that's the only way he wins. >> Yeah.
No, that's not true. But
>> BP Thompson just tipped $30. >> He needs to get
in a [__] like
>> into some killer ass
motivated by God. Second to none. >> A true Mark. Wow.
>> True Mark Ruffalo. Moving different brother. Wow. Well,
thank you so much for the 30 bucks, PP Thompson. Really appreciate
it, dude. Huge donuts. Merry Christmas, man. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you.
>> You You might have been saying there, did I miss you?
Say something there, Lav. I There's a donation coming
>> I don't think so. Ginger Ameth calling anyone a hilarious.
Is that true?
I don't think so. >> Wait, do we go to this right now?
Cold brew, you tell me to go to this right now. 3 hours 12 minutes.
I don't know what think you have an opportunity or an or >> realistic
um chance at all to do this. You're [__] terrible.
>> Here. Here. Come take a seat. Take a seat in the chair.
>> Did I jump forward too far? Oh, 2 hours 12 minutes.
Jesus. 3 hours 12 minutes. Hold on. We >> You guys do I
watch with my girlfriend. She's in Chicago right now watching.
All right. And uh yeah, shout out to Amma. And uh but no, thank
you for doing what you do, man. and you innovate and then everyone
else does it four years later. I'm like, "Yeah, ICE did that
5 years ago." So, >> yeah, that's why I'm here. >> What's
new? >> You're a real one. >> Thank you. >> So,
you're not here. He didn't hire you to do this. You're just doing
this. >> I'll send it to I'll send you the high res if
you want to message. >> Yeah, I'm not posting them anyway,
>> bro. What are you talking about, >> dude? Zena's
blowing me up saying, "Why are you pressing Kimmy?"
>> No, I told her to ask you for painting
>> That's what I'm saying. Yeah, because she wanted she
wanted >> people thinking that we're dating. What >> Nobody's
thinking that. >> No, but that's what Dude, it's live.
>> 3 hours 16 minutes. Sorry. Hold on. >> I asked
my girlfriend who has a history of cheating on me to message
you.
>> And you
>> I think it's not necessarily cheating. I said cuz I
was being colorful. I don't think it was cheating. I think they
were >> I look like a But guess what? I'm on KP making
above you. >> Hey, what happened? >> You banned me
on the Discord after >> Why' you ban me on the Discord?
>> Uh because
>> Cuz you said you wanted to your >> dude. Listen,
what daughter do I have? >> By the way, he clarified.
>> It is a weird thing. But look at the way
he feel. He literally said it's a fantasy, dude.
>> Ostracized, but I asked my girlfriend to ask you for
painting lessons.
If I did that, why am I not in prison? >> I'm not saying
you did it. I said you're a weirdo for saying that. >> It
is weird, but it's a script. >> Well, I'm guess a script.
Mike, after tonight, investigative units are going to be on your
know that >> investigative unit. >> I did. I said
crazy. >> You said the N like 50,000 times.
>> All right, dude.
>> Oh, this is pretty rough. >> That's your thing.
This this guy. Oh man, this is a rough rough one from this guy.
Okay. >> You said the hard ar. >> Yeah, I said Yeah,
I said the hard time. >> Yeah, I said it. Yeah. >> Yeah.
What about it? >> That's terrible. >> Yeah, the hard
racist. >> We have one more film.
>> So, if you're not here for that, please just leave
because this is this is >> who hasn't said the hard
>> me. I've never said it. >> Shut the up, Glink.
Glink. Get the out of here, dude. What the [__] is
he doing? Glink, yourself, Glink, you >> listen, guys.
>> Everybody says it,
>> you all you do is DM me the hard R.
Sorry. Okay. All right. This is after that. This is a little
bit later. Okay,
dude. It is funny actually that he comes out. And he's like,
"Guys, we have another movie playing."
>> because you're saying weird about the >> You didn't
even You don't even know about it. >> I do. I told her
to message you, you >> No, but you didn't tell her to say
that in the message.
>> Sorry, we weren't We were a little further in this.
>> I've only said positive things about you the day I met
you. >> Stop recording this.
I don't know. Remember when I walked into your room? >> Seems
like you know more than I do. >> I don't know. >> He
doesn't even know our interactions. >> I don't know anything.
>> Start recording. >> But you really think someone
that is coming up to press you is talking. >> No, we're
not. I'm not pressing you,
>> What I'm saying is trying to use his >> I definitely
don't trust him. That's >> I would never trust. >> Nobody
will ever press you while I'm >> Well, you're not going
to trust anybody >> The cobras are so good. >> One
more time.
They actually like unironically
I don't support deplatforming anyone. They should probably be
banned just for the sake of the content improving for
Like I I'm not saying that as like a actual I'm just saying it
would be good. Okay. It would be good. >> See, hold up.
Is this for >> one more time? >> Hey, Sor.
>> Come on, bro. >> Just paint it. That's how good
we look. Come on, bro.
>> Saying weird [__] bro. >> Dude, you
trust everything that Chad says. I get it.
>> Trust me. >> That's ironic, bro. >> Me that
saying stuff.
>> We're not hanging out now. >> I don't want to.
>> Well, now you switched up.
he's like hurt. He's like, actually, well, now you switched up,
man. Now you switched up.
That's ironic around me that are saying
>> We're not hanging out now. >> I don't want to.
>> Well, now you switched up.
>> You switched up, >> bro. What are you saying?
You literally talk and then just backst step as soon as you get
pressed. >> Talk [__] >> You say something
and then as soon as you get pressed, you just back down like
and act like you didn't say it. >> Eddie, man, we ain't
cool about that >> You can't be talking about Eddie around
here, man. We We >> Wait, does Jar know how this ends?
I do
>> We gang for Eddie, bro. The [__] wind is
blowing. >> Are you here for Eddie?
>> I love it. Wait, one more. One more.
>> De, man. >> I love
Darius is just over here dressed like he's going to a My Chemical
Romance concert in a group of people who are just like normal
people. >> Pushing a twist, man. >> You act. He's
so out of place. >> She got banned. >> Oh, really?
>> Damn. That's the CX effect.
>> Damn. I'm not going to lie. That's kind of crazy. He
said you're banned and you got banned. >> All right. Well,
these things happen.
>> Sorry, buddy. >> Just got roasted.
>> We'll go live on you got
>> 16. She banned. >> Are you still back? >> Did
he get cold or something? >> He got banned. >> I
got cold. >> He got cold. You got banned? >> No,
I didn't get >> You got banned on Twitch. >> Bro,
that's >> Yo, Westside. Mike, are you still back on Twitch?
The best platform in the >> I haven't looked. >> That's
crazy, dude. Imagine getting banned on Twitch around kick streamers.
Yeah, Kim really isn't. >> At least I said what I had to
say. >> Is that why you're Westside? >> Westside
Mike is saving nothing for the swim back. Listen, >> Give
me three months. >> What does that mean? >> Give
me three months. >> Wait, check how long you got banned.
>> I don't know. I got >> Check your email. check
your email
>> regardless. It doesn't matter. Like just check, bro.
We need to figure out so we can get you unbanned. >> This
was not for Clancy myself. >> This was not for the money.
This was purely for the viewers. >> I love you guys. >> This
is for you guys. >> Popcorn
around. >> I'm going to go to Sixth Street and
>> Nice to meet you guys.
>> Wait. All right, boys. >> Is that stale or something?
>> Yo. Oh, hell no. >> Bad ass.
I'm not
>> let you have some cheddar.
>> Yeah. Blink's coming. >> No, no, no. I'm good.
I'm good. >> Glink showing up with the snacks. >> Hell
no. >> Have some.
>> No, you try some.
>> Here. Have some.
>> Oh, saving nothing for the swim back is from Gatka.
I assume that's the same as burn the boats, right? As in I'm
committed completely. I have no backup plan. I'm all in on this.
Lot of different ways to say it. Are all these people wasted?
Hard to say. >> No, no, no. I'm good, >> bro. It
was a joke, bro. >> No, I only wanted to try one. I tried
one. I'm good. >> Have one. >> I did have one.
>> Don't throw it at me, dude. >> As long as you
got no animosity for
a joke. I'm
sorry. I'm sorry. I slapped your hand a little bit harder than
I understand, bro. You're serious about your food, bro. I understand.
No. Holy [__] This guy kicking it, dude. Who put
he You knew it. >> Here, Darus. I'm going to throw one.
Ready? I'mma throw one if you could do >> Ready? One, two.
>> Where the [__] is it, dude?
>> Dude, that's actually I don't I actually feel bad about
how much I laughed at that just now. That was actually funny
to me. Why was that funny to me? I'm such a
He like went for it and he couldn't see it and he
>> apolog 4 a.m. That just gets me. >> I literally
threw them up, bro. >> You're going to apologize to me
for that right now.
D apology,
Uh, you know the story about that girl who's there with Darius,
right? The girl I pointed out. She, uh, she met this princess
guy. Wait, is Lav still here even? Are you awake? Are you alive?
>> She met this princess guy first through Tinder and then
went to go hang out with him and met Darius while she was hanging
out with him. And
>> now she [__] Darius.
>> Darius really do be dirty mac and like all of his boys.
It's actually pretty crazy. It's pretty [__] up.
Like he literally can't stop himself.
There's no there's no bro code with this guy. Okay.
>> Hug it out. >> If there's any justice in the world,
it's that Hannah built him out of $20,000 in like a month and
disappeared
>> Oh, let P do it.
>> Dude, what the hell? And I don't want to have mine on
my side. >> No, there's no. >> Wait, you guys, somebody
asked if I know how this ends. Wait, is this not where it ends?
>> Is there more with Westside mic?
>> I'm on Shuy POV. I don't know where the next part is.
Is it with Shuy POV again? What? What's the next VOD? Where am
I going next? Cuz I don't see any more of Westside Mike on here.
>> Oh, there he is. He's inside.
I don't know where the next part is. Hold on.
Where where do we go on this? There's like the gooner bit. This
is them outside. Them outside. Them outside. See if I can find
a moment when they go
Is back outside. That still looked like it was Shu's VOD though,
right? Okay. We wait for them to go outside. I'm
>> Watching this guy play music with Ice here. Okay.
>> And then >> security, can you get this guitar
guy out of here? We're trying to count the votes. He's annoying.
>> It's okay. He's fine.
>> Just let him play. As long as Hey, it's >> Why
are you so faded?
>> What's the next What's the next one? Those are zombies.
>> Dude, they aren't just children. >> Do you not
You don't want to play guitar? I don't mind. That's what I'm
>> Stop. STOP BEING SO FOR MY GIRLFRIEND, you piece of
trying to sing to his girl.
>> What girl? Take the guitar outside.
>> just take it outside. They'll love you, >> dude.
You want me to go with you? >> I need an electric guitar.
>> Come on. Here. I'll go with you. >> I have an
electric. >> All right. Let me plug. >> It's too
late now. Just take that. Just take the best on YouTube. >> Let's
go. >> Okay. Can you
>> Yeah, I'm
Come here. >> Like, bro,
>> you're IRL view. >> All Hold on. Hold on. >> Yo,
get me past arguments.
>> You're IRL viewing, huh? >> Type [__]
that way. >> Is that just a random viewer?
>> Get a different point of view.
>> Ask them to come in. >> Like, bro, there's >> I'm
not doing those. Relax. >> Like, you remember what you
said? Raise your voice. We're >> Oh, is that yours? >> Dude,
calm down. >> Oh, so that's how it
>> you guys arguing, though. >> All right. Well,
enjoy the fire.
>> Enjoy the fire. >> So, you still got a new one,
Greg?
>> Okay. This one was
>> Hold on. There's another guitar in here. >> I'll
be one. I'll be quiet. >> No, that's the same. >> No,
you're good. You're good. You're >> You don't want the
guitar in here. >> HOW MANY GUITARS ARE THERE, MAN? >> You
just hate music. >> I took it from him. I'll play. >> It's
fine. It's my guitar and it's my house. It's fine. >> Do
you want me to? >> Yeah, you play. >> And then they
didn't. >> You just hate music, huh? >> Dude, I'm
trying to count the votes. >> I mean, you're not counting,
right? >> I'm just making sure it's legit auditing. Okay,
next phase.
>> We only have 15 responses. >> Two people did that.
>> We only have 15 responses. >> This is two. >> It's
not
>> Yo, China man, you going to see me on the big screen
someday.
>> Oh my god. Oh my god. >> OH MY GOD. >> Shut
up. You ching chong ramen noodle eating stir fry you [__]
>> This is so bad.
>> There's no way they're doing the accent,
>> dude. Okay. Sorry. I'm not going to watch I don't care
to watch the movie. I'm sorry.
>> Give me back to these two fighting. >> Yep. Yo,
>> girl is the horror story.
>> Have you seen the movie Danny >> for D10? All
right. >> YO, HAVE YOU SEEN THE MOVIE DANNY? THAT IS A
HORROR SHOW, DUDE. >> YO, which which one has the crazy
Whimo? Like he almost gets hit by the Whimo. >> Yeah, D10.
>> That's That's CX.
>> Hey,
we're still looking. >> I'm doing the No problem. >> I'm
doing the Roswell stream. >> When's that? >> Looking
for where Westside Mike is.
>> what was that?
>> What was that though? >> It's my ratchet on the
boat. Look.
>> Come on. Pull up, man. >> Hey yo, Bang Bangk.
>> Wait, is there another part here? I'm just going to
go.
>> Uh, you're saying weird stream
>> all banned mics on camera. I know. >> Playing
stupid. I don't care that too, bro. You're just Okay, cool. You're
>> No, you are not. >> You're not vouching for him,
>> bro. That's like the end. That was There wasn't anything
else. Wait, where was there more? I feel like we got baited.
I feel like we did watch all the way to the end. Should we hunt
Westside down later in the VOD? Okay. All right. I trust you.
Hunts him down like in his
Hold on. Hold on. Hey, it's Nick. Oh, THIS IS THE SAME NIGHT,
BRO. OH, Ice would have been losing it. I didn't know this was
the same night.
Oh, this is the same night where they go back to Ice's place
and then Kimmy pulls his bulletproof vest out and hits Shuy after
she puts it on Shuy.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Oh, no wonder he was so tilted, dude. I couldn't believe how
insanely tilted he was screaming at
Bro, he like has a breakdown. So, is the vest broken? >> No.
Oh, [__]
>> I mean, it's not a toy, right? It's not a toy. It's
for self-defense.
The, you know, plates are expensive. You, Kimberly,
thinking it's a toy. Is it
>> Uh, with this being how the night ends, I I think this
is it. You see the Westside Mike Zena DMs? I saw the DMs. We
pulled them up on screen real quick, but I didn't actually stop
and read them. Like, I saw that >> Oh, I maybe didn't see
them this well. Why would you try and act like Kimmy in your
DMs implying she's flirting with you and she never did that?
That's so lame to do that and attack her for that for a chat.
What are you talking about?
>> bro. They sent me the clip, bro. You got to be more
chill, especially when you're trying to get unbanned. Like, talk
about Kimmy wrong. It's not nice. You hit me up trying to be
my friend.
>> Shuy, just so you know, that girl you were just speaking
to with Darius is a trans and not a real girl. >> I gave
you a chance.
>> Oh [__] bro.
Cena gave me a chance after you sloppy thirds. >> Are you
kidding me?
>> Dude, she literally Yo, stop touching me, bro. She literally
said, >> dude, it's acting. Come on. >> She literally
said she gave you a chance to be a >> Okay, he's growing
on me slightly.
>> That's funny as Dude, it's acting. Come
>> Dude, she's still gone. She's still gone. We might need
to send her back to friends. It literally says, "You hit me up
trying to be my friend and I give you a chance." >> I was
just Dude, look at our messages. >> Also, bro, Congratulations.
>> She made a pinninging of you and she sent it to me.
Look at that, bro. Look at that, bro. >> Congratulations,
bro. Best of luck, >> dude. I don't even like
>> best of luck, bro, >> dude. Look at I'm down.
Sounds fun. Really talented. I'm
>> no follow cool down to chat. I think there is. I think
there's a six minute follow cool down for chatting.
Oh no, there isn't. I took I turned it off. Well, welcome. >> I
like more surrealism.
>> Westside mic is mentally. We're starting to pick that
up. Yes.
Mostly annoying, but in some ways that moment right there, that
was funny.
Okay, I get it. We watched this the other night where Ice just
presses Shuy over this dude. Ice
Ice do
Ice do need to be like I don't know needs to get Kimmy under
control somehow somehow someway. It's him blaming Shuy for this
on this night was kind of bull
to be honest with you. >> Uh yeah, let me let me uh explain
if I >> No, I don't want you to explain. I want you to
tell me. Is it broken? >> Well, yeah. A plastic piece on
it broke. >> Where's Kimberly at? >> I don't know.
She let Alexis out >> at some point during this. Doesn't
Ice yell like Kimmy's not allowed to leave her room or some [__]
>> He needs to do this, too.
>> cuz both of you are [__] stupid. >> I
understand. >> Like, bro, it's not a toy. >> Yeah,
I understand. >> Like, hitting it with a cutting board
is
>> I understand. >> Whose idea was that?
>> Um,
I mean, I could show you the clip. >> I saw the clip. >> Yeah.
Like, you're hidden. Like, it's not a toy, bro. Like, it's like
why? Like, you can wear it. That's fine, >> dude. But like
why [__]
>> the whole
if man
the whole thing is just a like masterclass in insecurity the
whole
>> You know when you hit armor enough times especially
really hard the integrity of it goes down. >> Yeah. So
>> minus 10 HP. Kimmy hits the the bulletproof vest with
a cutting board. Minus 10 HP. Minus 10 HP. minus 10. >> If
I wear that,
>> maybe it won't work if like I don't know. I'm not an
armor expert, but like I just know when you hit something a bunch,
the integrity of it will go down over time. Am I wrong? >> I
mean, you use ceramic plates, it'll probably be fine. But the
helmet, if you drop it from like even waist height, it can be
done. >> Okay. Nick's the guy who knows. Okay. Nick's the
only one here who's shot at a >> Well, that's a $2,000
helmet.
>> Were you guys playing with the helmet? There's no chance
they damaged the clip or whatever the cutting board. Oh, they
definitely did. They definitely like shattered the plastic clip
on the uh on the like body armor thing on the on the bulletproof
vest. That clip be shattered. They show it like the close-up
of it in the clip. Definitely shattered that clip in the in the
video clip. They definitely shattered the plastic clip that was
on the bulletproof
>> No, the helmet see helmet off the table. It was worn,
but it was not hit, dropped, nothing. And um >> the plate
will probably be fine. But uh
>> just try not to make racist comments again. Okay. >> The
racist commentary last time was not a good look. I'm going to
keep it to myself this time.
>> How long? >> That's my [__]
>> bro. This guy
Dude, what is the ear shape? What is the ear shape? Laugh. Can
you explain to me this ear shape, dude? Do human beings have
ears this shape?
Be real.
She got asleep. She like fell asleep, dude. It's I'm sorry. It's
like crazy.
>> Yeah. I
I I don't know what to say. >> How about you ask next time?
And that goes for her, too. Ask, "Hey, can we do this?" So, at
least I have an understanding and I can think it out real quick.
>> Shut up. You're a VTuber and problem.
So, you disagree with me? Hold on. Banglarp. So, you disagree
with me then? You You think that's a normal ear shape then? You
think that's a You think that's a normal ear shape? Yeah.
>> Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. >> I mean, wouldn't
that just be the most respectful thing? >> Yeah, absolutely.
>> These guys don't [__] do that.
Cobros didn't do it earlier. I gave them the best. They weren't
smacking it around. >> I guess I was under the impression
that it was like both of your guys' stuff. >> Oh, no. No.
Everything is mine.
No, there's not both of our [__] Everything's mine.
>> I misunderstood. I'm sorry. >> He's such a man.
He's such a big man. What a big strong man. >> Does it
actually >> It's a It's a plastic piece. >> It's
like one of those clips that you can clip like an attachment.
>> It's probably >> Yeah, that's just like >> You
can probably replace that, too. >> Notice the heat Mike
did. Ice didn't have for Mike. Ice had some of that heat for
Mike. Ice was yelling at Mike. >> Um should I? But it's
just like he knows he could yell at Shuy safely too. >> Like
I don't even know like should I go >> you're the lawyer,
dude. What are you
>> Uh do I give him money? Like I don't >> I would
probably I'll do that. Yeah, just offer to replace whatever broke
out, dude. >> Bro, it cost 800. No, that's that's the uh
ceramic plates that cost like >> 89% of that or whatever.
Okay. >> Yeah, the plate carrier is like >> the plate
carrier is Max buying a whole new one like 100 bucks. >> Okay,
well then I'll just do that. But he thinks that his whole plate
might be ruined. Like the integrity is broken. >> I didn't
see uh that part of it. I only saw the closing. >> You
didn't crack the plate, right? Well, it's not >> that definitely
it didn't like >> She didn't hit it that hard. I can >> surprising
like those like real expensive place. shot. Can someone send
the clip of her hitting me with it?
>> Cuz it can't die.
>> I'll just take him to come back. There he is. There
he is. >> Hey, I generate a clip of you breaking something
right now. Bubba, pack it up.
>> The clip's broken. >> Yeah, I'm going to reimburse
you. >> Here's the thing. It's not about reimbursing. Where's
the respect? Am I crazy or is it disrespectful
to with my without asking and then breaking it? Am I crazy? >> No.
In hindsight, that would >> No, you're very strong. You're
big and strong and strong and big. >> Absolutely very disrespectful
of me. And if I was you, I would be mad if somebody was playing
with my stuff and I found out that they broke it without my
So, I'm sorry for that. And I'm I want to reimburse you for it
because >> it's not about the reimbursement, dude. You
just It doesn't m It's just about >> That's the least that's
the least. about
>> and to try to show that I am sorry. That is the least
that I can do. I don't know what else that I can do to show that
I don't know what like >> if he's been out cuz unfortunately
for Ice, he's like the gravy train for all of these guys.
He's at that level now it seems like
where everybody, no matter what he does, everybody's just going
to apologize to him. They're going to try to make it right with
him. Like this is what turns you into the worst human being on
planet Earth, right? This exact
this exact like kind of dynamic, you will become the worst human
being imaginable. Like when you do terrible things to other people
and they're like, "Oh, I'm so sorry. Oh, I'm so sorry. I'm so
sorry I did this to you." >> I don't know what to say.
Like I can't say I didn't mean to. And you know it happened.
So
>> you can start by remembering that. Mine
>> I understand
>> I understand. Don't ever get her opinion for anything.
She has no opinion here.
>> She lives in that [__] room. She stays in
that room. >> [__] this [__] serious.
Is this Is this serious?
>> I think he's just pissed off. >> I don't know.
>> Chat. Chad, is this real? Chad, is this real? I still
don't even know. Like, am I Should I just leave? Like, I don't
even know what, Dude.
>> I just feel like I did something so wrong. But what
what can I do besides say I'm sorry. >> And they went to
Waffle House. Did they actually go to Waffle House?
I can't tell what they're doing at the end. That's a meme.
Should be so unintentionally funny. He is. He is like a funny
Shuy's like Shia buff in Transformers hanging out with anybody
ever.
He's just like a totally a fish out of water in every possible
scenario in real life,
right? He's meant to be like the the thing the audience like
identifies with. like wow what's going on all at all times dude
this is crazy >> freezing up here thank god is
next to me he's exuding
headache >> with his wife >> I'll see if Ice comes
back here
>> I think Ice is going to come back at some point pretty
soon I thought there was more of Ice forgot this guy went got
a coat >> I was unaware
>> you guys might personally have
>> ice came back though >> a clothes hanger and so
I was Ah, that probably won't do anything. And so it was she
wanted to try a drill and then she would run out with the clothes
hanger. And >> dude, Nick Nick found his people, man. Nick
found his people and he found his
All right. Took all of the energy he had to scream at Amaranth
and he applied it to something else and he's having success.
You love to see it. >> If he could put the vest on. >> Yeah.
It was like >> I bet you him and Amaranth are like way
better as a couple now, too. I bet you I bet you like Amaranth
and his marriage now that he's found this streaming thing he
can go do his own thing and off I bet you their marriage is like
infinity better unironically now that he's not trying to like
micromanage everything she's doing at all times to make her work.
I feel like Yeah, I just feel like whatever it is
it's got to be way better.
No, like I think they didn't like each other cuz Nick wanted
to make the business around her, right? I'm guessing that that
like him having to control her to do everything with the business.
Like that's not good.
So now he can just go out and do his own thing and then he can
come home and yeah, they're fine.
>> To be honest, we both went along with it. I literally
I'm not going to lie. I literally said like, "Do you have a bat?"
So, you know, I definitely played a role,
but thank God you don't have a bat. But I don't. >> All right.
All right. All right. All right. All right. I think that's uh
that's it for the stream, guys. Okay. W stream. That's cool.
I don't think anything else crazy happens from here. All right.
Okay. Let me see. I'll just wait and see if the if the chat says
there's like something crazy going on here right at the end,
but table. Oh, are you saying that Ice brought a taser out later
on the table? Well, crazy. Is Nick live right now? Oh, Nick was
live earlier, but I think he's no longer
Bro, kick is like crazy first thing in the morning. Like when
you're when you're when I stream like really late. We're like
in just chatting. I feel like we end up in like right at the
top of just chatting
like first row. We're literally the top stream in just chatting
English right now. Literally the top stream in just chatting
English.
Just a random PNG tuber.
We out here.
But that's cuz most of the other streams are not in English.
Like if I think if I turn English off,
we're third row. Third
Why would you turn English off? I don't even speak these other
languages.
Okay. All right. That's it, guys. I'll be back tomorrow.
Have a good night. I'll see youall later. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Good night.